GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN A MERCHANT
SEE AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES TO ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW%
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AGAIN EIGHT
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO
EIGHT THREE ONE. AGAIN THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE ONE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THE TIME YOU'LL BE
UN MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO DRESS THE COMMITTEE. NOW
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AS CHAIR I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE DRUG
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. NOW WE
HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA HOWEVER I SHOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
THREE THREE SIX FIVE EIGHT
CENTER IT'S ALL ABOUT IS BEING
WITHDRAWN FROM THE HEARING
TODAY AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR WE ALSO HAVE FOUR BILLS
ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY CENTER
TADO I NUMBER SIX SB FOUR FOUR
ONE BY CENTER TADO I AM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FIVE SIXTY FIVE BY
CENTER JONES AND ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB SIX EIGHTY TWO BY
CENTER RUBIO. THE BILLS WILL BE
HEARD IN AUTHOR ORDER THE ORDER
MAY BE MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE
VEIL ABILITY TO FILL AUTHORS TO
PRESENT. AND I NEED TO COMPLETE
THE HEARING AGENDA IN A TIMELY
MANNER. C. AT THIS POINT TIME I
DO NOT KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM THE ACT SO WE WILL
CONTINUE AS A SUB COMMITTEE- SO
WE WILL TAKE A TWO ONE TWO. SO
WE WON'T TAKE OUR ROLE AT THE
MOMENT WE'RE GOOD OKAY- SO WE
WILL WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENT FOR TAKING THE
ROLE SO CONTINUES AT THEY A
SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR BILL
TESTIMONIES DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
BILL TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE OF
THE PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT
OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. FOR THE PRIMARY%
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ALPERS PERMIT UP TO
TWO WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS OUR MAXIMUM FOUR
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. I DO HOPE TO
HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY HOWEVER BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE DEFINITE END TIMES FOR
THE HEARING. I MAY LIMIT THE
TOTAL TIME FOR ALL COMMENTS ON
THE BILL TO ENSURE THE
COMMITTEES ABLE TO COMPLETE OUR
HEARING AGENDA TODAY. EVERYONE
ALSO HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUBMIT TESTIMONY ON ANY BILL
BEING HEARD TODAY ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I WOULD MAKE
NOTE OF THAT- I DO KEEP TRACK
OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE
ARE SPENDING ON- PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND IF WE BEGIN TO
EXCEED FIFTEEN MINUTES TOTAL. I
MAY CREATE AN EASY TAP ON THAT
TIME WHICH WILL BE THE SAME FOR
BOTH. SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION-
LET'S SEE ONE TWO. THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN. THINK OF NO ONE
WE HAVE A- MEETING. OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
SKIP CONSULTANT. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF KEY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CAN HERE
MELENDEZ EGGMAN. GONZALEZ. GROF
FURTADO LEYVA. LIMON ROCK.
RUBIO WIENER. FOR OKAY THE CORE
OF A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SO WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST BILL I SEE
CENTER BRADFORD IS HERE'S OUR
FIRST ITEM IS SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE BY CENTER BRADFORD WELCOME.
AND- PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON HERE TO
PRESENT AS FIFTY FIVE TWO ONE.
WOULD SIMPLY INSURANCE
DEPARTMENT OF. HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS THE CLARITY AND
THE ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE AND
SIGN MEDICARE ALL DRUG. RELATED
CAUGHT REBATE CONTRACTS AS A
SAFE ALTERNATIVE TYPES OF
PAYMENTS OTHER THAN THE
STANDARD QUARTERLY TEMPLATES.
THAT IS EXISTED SINCE THE
NINETIES WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THIS ONE TIME TRANSFORMATIVE
GENE THERAPIES AND MANY OTHER
INNOVATIVE TREATMENTS ON THE
HORIZON MANUFACTURES AND-
SHARES ARE LOOKING FOR NEW WAYS
OF REIMBURSEMENT TO INCREASE
PATIENT ACCESS. MANAGE FISCAL
RISKS AND MAINTAIN
AFFORDABILITY. NEW TYPES OF
CONTRACTS THAT DO THIS ARE
CALLED VALUE BASED. OUR
PURCHASING AGREEMENTS THESE
CONTRACTS CAN SPECIFIED
PAYMENTS OVER TIME BASED ON
AGREED UPON OUTCOMES. IN OTHER
WORDS IF A TREATMENT DOESN'T
WORK THAT COULD MEAN NO MORE
REBATE FOR MATA CAL THIS BILL
PREPARES CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL
DRUG REBATE PROGRAM TO FOR
PATIENT ACCESS TO BE
TRANSFORMATIVE- TO
TRANSFORMATIVE TREATMENT BEING
DEVELOPED THAT MAY ONE DAY BE
ABLE TO CURE DISEASES LIKE
SICKLE CELL ANEMIA. I WANNA- WE
WANT MEDICARE HEALTH TO KNOW
THAT IT HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
START UTILIZING THESE TYPES OF
CONTRACTS SO THAT IT CAN ALSO
BE READY TO MAKE POTENTIALLY
CURATIVE TREATMENTS AVAILABLE
AS SOON AS THEY ARE. A REALITY
OTHER STATES SUCH AS WASHINGTON
MASSACHUSETTS ARIZONA TEXAS
OKLAHOMA AND MORE HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED- ST ABOUT MEN THAT
PAYMENTS TO HAVE VALUE BASED
PURCHASING AGREEMENTS FOR THEIR
MEDICARE PROGRAMS- CALIFORNIA
IS WILL BE JOINING THOSE STATES
BY SIMPLY PASSING SB. FIVE TO
ONE THAT PUTS US ON TRACK TO
CONTRACT AND ENSURE PATIENTS
AND THEIR DOCTORS CAN ACCESS.
OF THESE LIFE CHANGING
TREATMENTS I ALSO WANT TO GO ON
RECORD IN STATE THAT I
APPRECIATE THE WORK WITH THE
CHEER IN THE COMMUNITY AND WE
HAVE SOME ACCEPTED- RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND OUTLINE OF THE
BILL ANALYSIS SO AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR STAFF AND YOUR
WORK ON THIS MEASURE. AND HERE
TO TESTIFY SINCE HE TOOK ALL
THE TROUBLE TO COME INTO THIS
BUILDING AT THIS TIME AND EVEN
DRESS UP AND SHINING SHOES IS
NONE OTHER THAN JOHN VALENCIA.
WHO'S HERE ON BLUEBIRD BIO. AND
I THREE ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD APPRECIATE THAT
YOU BRING SOMEONE TO PROPECIA
STORE HEARING- SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH THE TEST
OF TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- SO-
MISTER VALENCIA AND FROM THE
GALLERY WELCOME- TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JOHN VALENCIA
REPRESENTING BLUEBIRD BIO WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH CENTER
BRADFORD PATIENT ADVOCATES AND
OTHER COMPANIES THAT ARE
STRIVING FOR CURES. WITH
TARGETED TO DISEASES LIKE
SICKLE CELL DISEASE TRANSFUSION
DEPENDENT BETA THALASSEMIA
CEREBRAL ADRENO LEUKODYSTROPHY
MULTIPLE MYELOMA. THE VEHICLES
FOR ACCOMMODATING THESE
TREATMENTS WILL BE VALUE BASED
AGREEMENTS. VALUE BASED
AGREEMENTS ARE JUST CONTRACTS
AND THEY'RE DESIGNED TO ANSWER
TWO QUESTIONS OUR PATIENTS
GETTING THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
ALL HOPE FOR AND AS MEDICAL
GETTING WHAT THE VALUE OF WHAT
IT'S PAYING FOR. CENTER
REDFORD'S FIVE TWENTY ONE WILL
PERMISSIVE LEE PER POSITION
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN NINE OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
MODIFIED THEIR DRUG REBATE LAWS
OR MOVE FORWARD
ADMINISTRATIVELY. TO BE
POSITIONED TO ACCOMMODATE VALUE
BASED AGREEMENTS AND
MEDICATIONS THAT WILL BE
CAPTURED IN THOSE. THE FDA IS
ANTICIPATED TO APPROVE THE
MEDICATIONS AS SOON AS THIS
TIME IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- THAT WOULD
TAKE A DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWENTY ONE
BEGAN WITH THE GALLERY SCENE NO
ONE ELSE AT THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SAYING NO AND IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES TO- PEOPLE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO- TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS STAR FOLLOWED
BY THE ONE EXCUSE ME ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO. TO PUT
YOURSELF IN Q. ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND OUR FIRST PERSONAL B.
LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIFTY TWO. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR JENNIFER SNYDER
REPRESENTING THE BIOTECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TO ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT PURCHASE IT WILL
BE FROM LYING SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS EMILY PAPPAS WITH
NEYMAR PAPPAS ASSOCIATES IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF CRISPR
THERAPEUTICS THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. BETTER
LATER TO- GO AHEAD AND TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TO ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY
ZERO PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW. TURN TO
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE WHO IS A REGISTERED
TO GIVE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT- IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE WILL BE ON THE GALLERY.
SCENE ON THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THREE
KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MUCH- IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR WE'LL GIVE
YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE A
PLACE YOU BACKING . AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS. ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT.
BE WITH US MOMENTARILY. THANK
YOU AND WE WILL GO TO LIVE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI YES OF THE FOR THEM IS THAT
THEY RESIDENT FROM SAN DIEGO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THANK YOU THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. SB. FIVE TO ONE.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS GIVING
UP OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANYONE AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ON REMOTELY. OKAY
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION FROM
CENTER ROTH SAYS SAN BRADFORD
AT FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT-
COMING DOWN THE LINE ACTUALLY
NEXT COMING ALONG IT'S HERE IS
THAT WE'RE HAVING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW THERAPIES-
OFTEN EVEN CURATIVE THERAPIES-
THAT. ARE VERY EXPENSIVE TO
DEVELOP- THEY CAN'T SAVE US
MONEY IN THE LONG RUN- BECAUSE
OUR CHURCHES- BUT THEY MAY HAVE
VERY LARGE UP FRONT COSTS AND
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO FINANCE THAT
AND ALSO ENSURE WE CAPTURED
THAT VALUE FOR OUR PATIENTS
PARTICULAR MEDICAL PATIENTS IN
THE STATE SO CERTAINLY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS BILL
FOR TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THE YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I PRE AGAIN YOUR WORK
ON THIS AND YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE FIELD OF MEDICINE IN AND OF
ITSELF. AGAIN SINCE THE STREET
FOR MEASURE TO- KEEP TWO GIRLS
ARE AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN THE
DESIRED OUTCOME AS- THE CHEER
STATED OF COMING WITH NEW
CURATIVE MEASURES TO. READ OUR
PATIENTS OF LIFE THREATENING
DISEASES THAT STILL EXISTS
TODAY AND IT ALLOWS US IN THOSE
COMPANIES WHO ARE BEING. THE
CUTTING EDGE TO THE DO IT IN
AFFORDABLE AND MANAGEABLE WAY
AND ON THAT NOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. HEY THANK
YOU CENTER BRADFORD THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER ROCKING
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HAND HI
CAN I AM MELINDA'S SIDE
MELENDEZ BY. EIGHT MINUTES HI
GONZALEZ. CONSOLES I GROW. HER
TADO. LEYVA HI LEYVA EILEEN
MOANED. ROSS HI ROSS I RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER. THE CURRENT
LOTUS SEVEN ZERO HOLD THE BILL
OPEN FOR IT ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU. MUCH OKAY NEXT NEXT
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
BY CENTER DIED WELCOME MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I S. B.
SEVEN ONE SEVEN WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT ACCESS FOR MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WILL DEPEND ON SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT REFER TO AS COMPLEX
REHAB TECHNOLOGY OR C. R. T.
FOR SHORT TO MEET THEIR UNIQUE
MEDICAL PHYSICAL AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS. THE SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
ACCOMPLISHES THREE IMPORTANT
OBJECTIVES OF PROTECTING
CRITICAL ACCESS TO C. R. T. IT
CONFORM C. R. T. COACH THE
CURRENT FEDERAL STANDARDS IN
CLINICAL BEST PRACTICES THAT
ENSURE PATIENTS ARE PROPERLY
EVALUATED AND SERVICED BY
QUALIFIED CREDENTIAL PROVIDERS
IT REQUIRES D. C. H. D. H. C.
S. TO CONSIDER THE RESOURCE
INTENSIVE DELIVERY MODEL C. R.
T. IN THE STABBING SHE FUTURE
POLICIES AND PAYMENT RATES IT
PROTECTS ACCESS TO SPECIALIZED
C. R. T. PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
BY REPEALING THE TEMPORARY AB
9710% MEDI. MEDI CAL PAYMENT
RATE CUTS CURRENTLY C. R. T.
PROVIDERS ARE RECOGNIZED AND
REIMBURSED BY MEDICARE ALL AS
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT OR
DMP FOR SHORT- DESPITE
SIGNIFICANTLY AND COSTLY
DIFFERENCES IN THE DELIVERY OF
C. R. T. UNLIKE DMB C. R. T.
PRODUCTS REQUIRE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF QUALIFIED
PROVIDERS FOR THE VALUATION
PROVISION AND ONGOING SUPPORT
TO THE PATIENTS OFTEN PROVIDED
THE PATIENT'S OWN HOME HOWEVER
STATE REIMBURSEMENT POLICY DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE UNIQUE LABOR AND
INTENSIVE ACTS ASPECTS OF C. R.
T. NOR THE TRANSPORTATION COSTS
OF TRAVELING TO THE PATIENT'S
pLOCATION. COST PRESSURES HAVE
RESULTED IN DWINDLING NUMBERS
OF PROVIDERS IN THE STATE
CAUSING SIGNIFICANT WAIT TIMES
AND DELAYED CARE FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ACCESS TO C. R. T.
IS OFTEN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AN INDIVIDUAL LIVING
INDEPENDENTLY IN MORE EXPENSIVE
FACILITY BASED CARE USED
PROPERLY IT HELPS PROMOTE
INDEPENDENCE AVOIDS
INSTITUTIONALIZATION IT REDUCES
RELATED MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY IS DON CLAY BACK
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL COALITION FOR
ASSISTIVE AND REHAB TECHNOLOGY
AND JACQUI KIRKWOOD REGIONAL
DIRECTOR. FOR NATIONAL SEATING
AND MOBILITY. RIGHT THANK YOU
SO DOT LET'S NOW TO TEST MAIN
SUPPORT SOME. T. PLEASE BRING
ON THE- FOR TWO. DONALD CLAY
BLACK. AND JENNIFER KIRKWOOD
AND I BELIEVE DONALD PLAY BACK
AS BEGINNING SO- TWO MINUTES-
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
BOTH OF YOU SO MISS CLAY BACK
TO BE RUN OVER. BY LEFT IN THIS
LAST TIME FOR THIS GUY FOR
JACQUI KIRKLAND. ALL RIGHT
THESE BIG THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR AND I BY WILL SPEAK
QUICKLY- MY NAME IS- DON CLAY
BACK I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL COALITION FOR
ASSISTIVE AND REHAB TECHNOLOGY.
WE REPRESENT THE PROVIDERS AND
MANUFACTURERS OF THE TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT SENATOR DODD
DESCRIBED BY MORE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN-
COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY ITEMS
INCLUDE. MEDICALLY NECESSARY IN
INDIVIDUALLY CONFIGURED MANUAL
ON POWER CHAIRS- POWER
WHEELCHAIRS SEATING AND
POSITIONING SYSTEMS AND OTHER
ADAPTIVE EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
STANDING DEVICES. GAIT TRAINERS
THE SPECIALIZED PRODUCTS ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH A SMALL
NETWORK OF CERTIFIED SUPPLIERS
AND ARE USED BY A SMALL
POPULATION. OF CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES AND MEDICAL
CONDITIONS SUCH AS CEREBRAL
PALSY ALS SPINAL CORD INJURY.
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS. AND SPINA BIFIDA.
THEY'RE VERY LOW NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED SEE TO PROVIDE. IN
KILL. AND MEMBERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE THE
MEDICARE POPULATION DUE TO THE
ONGOING AB 9710% CUTS WHICH
HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE UP FOR
MANY YEARS AND WERE DESIGNED TO
BE TEMPORARY- CODE NINETEEN
EXPENSES THAT CONTINUE TO
MOUNT. AN UPPER BILLION LIMIT
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE PART OF
THE PAYMENT POLICIES. ARE
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS HAVE TOLD ME
THAT WITHOUT REIMBURSEMENT
IMPROVEMENTS THEY WILL BE
FORCED TO MAKE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS SUCH AS LIMITING
PRODUCT CHOICE. THIRTEEN REPAIR
SERVICES IN THE HOME AND
SCALING BACK ON ALL OTHER
SERVICES PROVIDED IN THE
FACILITIES OBVIOUSLY THIS WOULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT MEDICARE
CLIENTS THAT MUST E AVOIDED.
UPDATING THE C. R. T.
REGULATIONS AND PROVIDING A
SMALL INVESTMENT. IN RESTORING
AND STABILIZING C. R. P. T.
PAYMENTS. WILL FURTHER PROTECT
THE SMALL AND FRAGILE
POPULATION BY INCREASING ACCESS
TO CARE AND AVOIDING NEGATIVE
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES. WE THANK
SENATOR DODD FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS CONSIDERATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NOW
LET'S I JACQUI KIRKWOOD YOU
HAVE A FULL TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PAN
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JACKIE KIRKWOOD AND I AM THE
REGIONAL AREA DIRECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA FOR NATIONAL
THINKING ABILITY WHICH IS A
LEADING PROVIDER OF COMPLEX
REHAB TECHNOLOGY. WE PROVIDE
THE CRITICAL REHAB TECHNOLOGY
TO CHILDREN AND ADULTS IF YOU
CAN'T DISABILITIES YOUR SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA LOCATION. TODAY I'M
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT SENATE
BILL SEVEN ONE SEVEN WHICH
ENSURES ACCESS TO THE CRITICAL
EQUIPMENT FOR OUR VULNERABLE
POPULATION OF PATIENTS. WE IN
EUROPE ENJOY OUR WORK WITHIN
THE VERY DEMANDING AND LOW
MARGIN INDUSTRY SERVING PEOPLE
WITH HIGH LEVEL PHYSICAL NEEDS
AND CHALLENGES HOWEVER WE ARE
FACED WITH SIGNIFICANT
OPERATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. AND MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT RIGHT BEFORE THE
STATE SHUT DOWN THE ENACT
PROVED A STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
THAT TIED TO YOUR TEETH MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT TO THE LOWEST
PUBLISHED MEDICARE FEE SCHEDULE
ALLOWABLE THIS IN ADDITION TO
THE ONGOING 89710% RATE
REDUCTION. THAT WAS MEANT TO BE
TEMPORARY TO STOP THE STATE
BUDGET DEFICIT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE BUT INSTEAD HAS BECOME A
PERMANENT CUTS ARE INDUSTRY.
PRIOR TO THE STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT THE EXISTING 10% RATE
CUT HAS RESULTED IN CHALLENGES
THAT INCLUDE MERGING AND
CLOSING OF LOCATION AND
INCREASED WAIT TIMES FOR OUR
CLIENT. CLIENT ARE EVEN FORCED
TO PHYSICALLY GO TO A BRANCH
LOCATION FOR FASTER SERVICE.
YOU TO REDUCE SERVICE COVERAGES
IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THE
WORLD COUNTY. WITH THIS THE NEW
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT FURTHER
CUTTING OUR RATE MY COMPANY IS
CONCERNED THAT WE MAY BE FORCED
TO CONTINUE TO LIMIT PRODUCT
SELECTION OPTIONS AND AT HOME
SERVICE CALLS WHICH TRANSLATES
INTO HIGHER REPAIR COSTS. AND
LET THE QUALITY EQUIPMENT BEING
SUPPLIED TO THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT MOST ADDITIONALLY WITH THE
COBRA NINETEEN PANDEMIC THIS
REPRESENTATIVE ST MARY
CHALLENGES RELATED TO
MAINTAINING ACCESS FOR OUR
CLIENTS. THANK YOUCHALLENGES
WITH STAFFING AND INCREASED
DIFFICULTY IN PROCUREMENT OF PP
AND THE LIMITATIONS. TO
INVESTMENT TELEHEALTH WE HAVE
AVAILED AND CONTINUE TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR PAY. THAT WE CAN'T
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER. OF THE SENATE THE
SEVEN SEVEN. WHICH WILL
STRENGTHEN THE- FOR INCREASED
PROTECT. AND OUT FOR PATIENTS
WITH SIGNIFICANT JUST. THIS
BILL. SUPPLY PLEASE WRAP UP.
WINTER AT TO ALL WHICH I KNOW
IS YOUR TOP THREE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THAT LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME A
POSITION AND- WHAT NAME ONLY
TAKES POSITION ONLY WILL BEGIN
GALLERY. SAYING ON THE GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THREE KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF S. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS.
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THE STRUCTURE AND OUR
FIRST ONE WILL COME FROM WIND
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE MOMENT WE'RE
JUST GETTING SOME QUEUING UP
RIGHT NOW SURE PLEASE BEAR WITH
US AS WE GET GIVEN THEIR LINE
NUMBER SORRY MISTER CHAIR.
SHOULD HAVE WON A SECOND I
THINK. OKAY AND. WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY FOURTH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. X. WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THE WHITE C.
M. ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHT CALIFORNIANS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER JERRY MEMBERS
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
OPPOSITE THAT THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
ADMITTED SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
NUMBERS BOB ACKERMAN THE HAVE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MEDICAL PRODUCTS SUPPLIERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. AND
AGAIN IF THERE ARE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT AND
S. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE.
EUROPE AT. THANK YOU MISTER
TERRY MEMBERS CHEATING LAYTON
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU EXLINE. OUR NEXT. I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE- AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO- TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ON S. B. SEVEN ONE
SEVEN WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
LISTED FOR FORMAL TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE'LL NOW MOVE-
TO A PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION START
WITH THE GALLERY SCENE KNOWN AT
THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN ONE
SEVEN. MODERATOR. YES THANK YOU
A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SORRY IT WAS
MUTED. ALL RIGHT ALL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY THAT OPPOSITION. MR
CHERNOBYL IS QUEUING UP OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH NOW LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE OR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. K. SEEING
NONE- SO CENTER DIED I WANT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND- AND CERTAINLY
VERY IMPORTANT PEOPLE OF ACCESS
AS SOMEONE WHO IS A PHYSICIAN
IS TAKING CARE OF- PATIENTS WHO
HAVE DISABILITIES AND NEED THIS
TACTIC TECHNOLOGY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE BE SURE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU- IS THERE A MOTION I
SEE CENTER ROTH HAS MOVED TO
THE BILL SO THE MOTION IS FROM
SAN RAFEAL IS DUE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI
CAN I AM LINDA'S HI MELENDEZ
AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I GREW.
HER TAUGHT I FIR TOTAL I LAY.
LEYVA AYE LIMA. ROTH FIVE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE. OKAY THE BILL
CURRENTLY IS NINE ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT-
AUTHORS AS A NUMBER SORRY THANK
YOU SIR GO DOLLARS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY YOUR DESK IF I
CAN ALTHOUGH OKAY SO WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB TWO FORTY FIVE BY
SARAH GONZALEZ BEFORE WE BEGIN
I UNDERSTAND OR MAYBE SOME.
SOME SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THIS BILL IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WE STAY ON
SCHEDULE I'M GOING TO AFTER THE
FORMAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND
THEN THE OPPOSITION WILL ALLOW
UP TO TWENTY MINUTES OF- PUBLIC
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT AN
EXPRESSION OF OUR EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITIONS ALLOW
TWENTY MINUTES EQUAL TIME ON
EACH SIDE UP TO THAT TIME
AMOUNT OF TIME AND CERTAINLY
PEOPLE WANT TO CONTINUE MAKE
COMMENTS THEY CAN SEND THEIR
COMMENTS DIRECTLY TO OUR
COMMITTEE BY. VIA OUR WEBSITE
SO WITH THAT- SERGEI DOLLARS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MANAGEMENT'S MENTION
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
TWO FOUR FIVE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE ALL STATE LICENSED
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS
ISSUED AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THE COVER ABORTION AND ABORTION
RELATED SERVICES WITHOUT A
COPAYMENT DEDUCTIBLE OR ANY
TYPE OF COST SHARING.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
LEADER IN PROTECTING AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ARE
SERVICES AND ALMOST FIFTY YEARS
SINCE THE SUPREME COURT
ESTABLISHED THE LEGAL RIGHT TO
ABORTION ADVOCATES AT FOUGHT TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO CARE AND
MAINTAINING OUR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOMS WELL THESE EFFORTS
HAVE HELPED MAINTAIN THIS RIGHT
FOR CALIFORNIANS THERE ARE
STILL NUMEROUS BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING THESE SERVICES
INCLUDING AFFORDABILITY HEALTH
PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO COVER
ABORTION SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THEY STILL CAN
CHARGE HIGH DEDUCTIBLES COPAYS
THAT CAN RANGE FROM FORTY
DOLLARS TO THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
A FIVE YEAR STUDY CONDUCTED BY
UCS HALF OF THE ONE THOUSAND
WOMEN SEEKING ABORTION CARE AT
THIRTY FACILITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FOUND THAT OVER. HALF
OF THE WOMEN HAD OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSE THIS IS A MORE THAN ONE
THIRD OF THEIR- IN. THESE HIGH
OF POCKET COSTS ARE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO CARE TO
THE CARE THAT CAN BE COST
PROHIBITIVE. FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. ADDITIONALLY THE
COSTS OF AN ABORTION RISES
SIGNIFICANTLY AS JUST STATION
ADVANCES. SB TWO FOUR FIVE WILL
REMOVE THIS BARRIER AND ALLOW
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS
THEIR LEGAL RIGHT. TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR SERRA
ROBERTS WITH THE BIXBY CENTER
FOR GLOBAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AT UCSF. AND BELLA GALLIMORE A
CALIFORNIAN WHO FACE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS TO CARE AS WELL AS
FIVE YOU LOOK IT ON AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE NATIONAL HEALTH LAW
PROGRAM. I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU CENTER GONZALES AND JUST TO
CLARIFY I UNDERSTAND THAT-
FIBULAR CARRY ONS FOR QUESTIONS
ONLY ALL RIGHT FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OKAY. SO MODERATOR
KEEP PLEASE BRING ON TO LINE
DOCTOR SERRA ROBERTS AND DELEK
COLUMN MORE- FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY AND- THE REMINDER IS
THAT- YOU'RE ALLOWED TWO
MINUTES APIECE FOR A TOTAL OF
FOUR MINUTES OF. THE FIRST ONE
RUNS OVER DEL GOES AWAY FROM
THE TIME FROM THE SECOND PERSON
I WILL STOP. CAPITA FOUR
MINUTES. SO WE CAN BREEZE
PLAYING ON FIRST THE DOCTOR
SERRA. ROBERTS TO TESTIFY. I DR
ROBERT YOUR LIFE SHOULD BE OPEN
GO AHEAD NINE MUTE YOURSELF.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SARAH
ROBERTS AND I AM IN A FIFTEEN A
PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGY AND
REPRODUCTIVE SCIENCES. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. I THIRTY THE IMPACT
THE STATE LEVEL PERSON POLICIES
AND PUBLISHED MORE THAN FIFTY
PEER REVIEWED ARTICLES ABOUT
ABORTION. INCLUDING MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE THAT DIRECTLY
EXAMINE THE IMPACT OF STATE
LEVEL ABORTION POLICIES. MY
RESEARCH AS WELL AS OTHER PEER
REVIEWED RESEARCH. THE COST OF
A PORTION OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BERRIER PEOPLE FACE
TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN AN
ABORTION. PEOPLE FEW WAYS.
FIRST OFF THE FACT OTHER AREA
PEOPLE TO CONNECT LIVE.
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
HAVING TO COME UP WITH THE
MONEY TO PAY FOR AN ABORTION
OUT OF POCKET. WE'LL HAVE TO DO
THINGS LIKE PUT OFF. OR SKIP
PAYING RENT OR BUYING FOOD.
SECOND COST CONTRIBUTED DELAYED
AND ONE OF THE THIRTY VERY MUCH
BEFORE BUT HALF OF THE
PARTICIPANTS REPORTED THAT
HAVING TO RAISE MONEY TO PAY
FOR THE ABORTION WITH
EVERYTHING THEY WERE DELAYED.
WHEN PEOPLE WORK WITH A PERSON
FROM A FAMILY WITH A MAN
INVOLVED IN THE PREGNANCY.
MONEY TO PAY FOR AN ABORTION.
IT CAN TAKE AWHILE TO GET THE
MONEY TOGETHER. PEOPLE ARE
DELAYED UNTIL THE SECOND
TRIMESTER THE COMPANY WHERE SHE
GOT THAT. WHICH CAN THEN LEAD
TO FURTHER DELAY PEOPLE BURKE
TO RAISE ADDITIONAL. THE TWENTY
YEAR OLD EXPLAINED TO US IN ONE
OF OUR IDEAS. I GET PAID EVERY
WEEK AND EVERY TIME I THINK I
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY. TAKEN OUT IN
TAXES. I'M JUST UNDER THE
AMOUNT THAT I NEED. EVERY TIME
I TRY TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT
SOMETHING ELSE COMES UP THAT I
HAVE TO PAY. THIRD MOST PEOPLE
OBTAIN ABORTIONS RIGHT BECAUSE-
BUT SOME DO NOT. SOME PEOPLE.
MULTIPLE MONEY. ACOSTA BECAUSE
SO MUCH IN THE MEANTIME. BUT
THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT WHAT THE
BILLION LEAD TO THEM BEING
BEYOND THE JUSTICE MOMENT. FOR
A PORTION CARE IN THEIR STATE.
THIRTY THREE I YOUR SUPPORT AND
I'M A FAILED FOR QUITE. THANK
YOU- THAT'S NOW MOVE ON BALLOT
WATER AND YOU HAVE TO BE AND-
FOR SECONDS. TO GIVE YOU LOOKS
TIME. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BELLA
GALLIMORE AND I'M AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO. IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
MEDICAL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC I
WAS SHOCKED TO DISCOVER THAT I
WAS PREGNANT- THE TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD LIVING TO MY FIRST
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WHICH HAD
ALREADY COST ME MY JOB AND
SOCIAL LIFE. I THOUGHT IN NO
WAY PREPARED TO TAKE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF A CHILD
DURING SUCH UNCERTAIN TIMES AND
I MADE THE DECISION TO HAVE AN
ABORTION. I SCHEDULED AN
APPOINTMENT AT MY LOCAL CLINIC
AND MENTALLY PREPARED FOR THE
EXPERIENCE I WOULD UNDERGO. BUT
I COULD NOT PREPARE FOR IT WITH
THE FINANCIAL BARRIER I FACE
WHEN ACCESSING MY PORTION. ON
THE DAY OF MY APPOINTMENT I
LEARNED THAT UNDER MY
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE POLICY I
WOULD NEED TO PAY SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO HAVE THE PROCEDURE
THAT DAY. THIS COST COMPLETELY
BLINDSIDED ME AND I
CONTEMPLATED HOW I COULD AFFORD
THE PROCEDURE. IN ADDITION TO
MY LIVING EXPENSES. I THEN
UNDER. THAT OF URGENCY WITHOUT.
ABORTION I KNEW THAT THE LONGER
I WAITED THE MORE EXPENSIVE IT
WOULD BE. I WAS FORCED TO MAKE
AN IMPOSSIBLE DECISION THAT DAY
CAN I USE NEARLY ALL THE MONEY
I HAD TO PAY FOR MY ABORTIONS.
AFTER PAYING FOR THE PROCEDURE
I WENT TO MY CAR. AND I THOUGHT
FOR MYSELF AND EVERYONE ELSE
WHO KNEW THE DISTRESS CAUSED BY
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
HEALTH CARE. AT THE MOST
VULNERABLE TIME IN MY LIFE THE
FINANCIAL BARRIER I STATE TO
COST SHARING ALMOST PREVENTED
ME FROM ACCESSING THE CARE THAT
I NEED THAT. THE BURDEN OF THIS
HIGH AND EXPECTED COST AFFECTED
ME FINANCIALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
FOR WEEKS AFTERWARD. THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR COST OF MY
ABORTION INTENSIFIED MY
FINANCIAL TROUBLES CAUSED BY
THE PANDEMIC. AND THE EXISTING
STIGMA SURROUNDING ABORTION
MANY FEEL ISOLATED AND
VOICELESS. PEOPLE THAT I COULD
UNDERGO A FACE AND LEGAL
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT IT WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR ME. I RECOGNIZE
NOW THAT THE TRONG MIND OR DO%
TO COST SHARING SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED. I'M ASKING FOR
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL CHIU
FORTY FIVE. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE
THE OTHER CALIFORNIANS WILL NOT
ENCOUNTER THE SAME FINANCIAL
BARRIER I THINK WHEN I COULD
SEE MY PORTION. THANK YOU TO
SHARE MY STORY TO SERVE AS A AS
AN EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS URGENTLY NEEDED
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WITH THAT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FORTY FIVE
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITIONAL
BEGAN WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAY NO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE TWO WITNESSES WHO IS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY FIVE AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
BEGAN TO SO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH WINE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB BECKEL
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS DAN FLORI WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE ALL. NINE
THIRTY SIX. THANK THEIR
TEACHERS CAN YOU HEAR US. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. SORRY
ABOUT THAT IT'S BEEN WITHIN HER
HEAD OF PHILLY AT THE
CALIFORNIA PROCOPE OPTED TO
DEPART THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL MOVE TO
LINE SIXTY SEVEN. HI KATHY
DONALDSON REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT TIME HE- X. WE WILL GO TO
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. BY NINETY SEVEN YOUR UP.
HI YES I WAS NOT GIVEN- AND
TWENTY TWO OPPOSE OR SUPPORT
BUT I DO OPPOSED THIS I'M LISA
HOBBY WHILE IMPACTING
OPPOSITION LATER SO- PLEASE GET
BACK ON THE LINE FOR THE
OPPOSITION. UP NEXT LINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FINAL CALL ME
NEARLY HALF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANKS WILL GO TO I. NINETY
THREE PLEASE CONTACT. HI THIS
IS SHANNON OLIVIERI HOLDEN FROM
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE COULD SPONSOR
ON THE BILL AND YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. FIND
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WILL BE A PATIO WITH A SIMPLE
ACCESS HELP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
ONE EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THERE
THE STATEMENT WITH ON ACTIVE
PROJECTS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. THANK
YOU AS A FINAL REMINDER FOR SB
TWO FORTY FIVE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND WE WILL GO TO ONE NINETY
NINE. MAKING LAND SHOT I'M A
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA WPI ST FELLOW AND
DRUNK THE PORT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. WE'LL GO TO ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JESSICA
PINCKNEY THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR%
OF ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF SB TWO FORTY FIVE AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. YEAH MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION TESTIMONY I HAVE-
FOR TESTIMONY WE HAVE A
BOUNDARY BRING ON SUSAN ARE NOW
FROM THE- RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE.
AND PAMELA VERA. AS THE TO TEST
THE FIRES AND JUST AGAIN A
REMINDER- IT'S TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS BUT ACTUALLY IT'S A
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER SO
IF- THE FIRST ONE GIVES A
LITTLE EXTRA TIME I'LL GIVE IT
TO THE SECOND PERSON AND IF
THEY USE THAT MORE TIME THAT'S
A LITTLE LESS PERSON FOR THE
SECOND TEST OF FIRE SO- I WILL
GIVE A TWO MINUTE WARNING OUT.
ANNOUNCE THE TWO MINUTE MARK SO
THAT THE FIRST TESTIMONY THE
TEST FILE NO WHEN THAT HAPPENS-
BUT HE PLEASE BRING SUSAN ARE
NOW ON TO THE LINE. I'M HERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES NOW PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSAN ON
ALL I'M AN ATTORNEY FROM THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE AND WE
OPPOSED SB TWO FORTY FIVE.
FIFTY TWO FORTY FIVE WILL FORCE
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO PAY FOR
ABORTION FREE OF CHARGENO
DEDUCTIBLES NO CO PAYS.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY REQUIRES ALL
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
TO COVER ABORTION THIS BILL
FORCES INSURANCE TO PICK UP THE
TAB AS WELL. THE BILL'S
PREFERENCE FOR FREE ABORTIONS
OVER OTHER TYPES OF HEALTH CARE
IS INCONSISTENT SEXIST
DISCRIMINATORY AND DOUBLE DOWN
ON CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW SB TWO
FORTY FIVE IS INCONSISTENT WHY
STOP AT ABORTION COPAYS. WHY
NOT FORCE INSURANCE COMPANIES
TO ABSORB COPAYS FOR OTHER
WOMEN'S HEALTH TREATMENTS LIKE
PAP SMEARS HYSTERECTOMIES OR
FERTILITY TREATMENTS OR EVEN
CANCER AND IT'S SEXIST. WHY NOT
COVER MEN'S REPRODUCTIVE ISSUES
LIKE ERECTILE DYSFUNCTION OR
PROTECTING THE REVERSAL AND
WHAT ABOUT SIX CHANGE
OPERATIONS WHY IS ABORTION FREE
FOR ALL. SB TWO FORTY FIVE IS
DISCRIMINATORY MOST PREGNANCIES
DO NOT END IN ABORTION SB TWO
FORTY FIVE DOES NOT REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO PAY FOR THE COST
OF GIVING BIRTH. EFFORTS TO
ADOPT IT SELECTIVELY
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST FAMILIES
AND WOMEN. WHO WANT TO GIVE
BIRTH. SB TWO FORTY FIVE
VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW. WELL
AMENDMENT CLEARLY STATES THAT
HEALTH PLANS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO COVER OR PAY FOR ABORTIONS.
FLOUTING THIS FEDERAL LAW
CALIFORNIA ALREADY REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO INCLUDE
COVERAGE FOR ABORTION SB TWO
FORTY FIVE DOUBLE DOWN ON THIS
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW TO
SELECTIVELY REDISTRIBUTE FUNDS
FROM PRIVATE COMPANIES. TO
ABORTION PROVIDERS IN A BID TO
ADVANCE A SOCIALIZED MEDICAL
CARE PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE FOR
THESE REASONS WE URGE A NO VOTE
ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
PAMELA VERA AND YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE FIFTY SIX FIVE SECONDS.
SO FAMILY VERA. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YES WEEKEND PLEASE BEGIN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PAMELA
VERA AND NOT PERSONAL STORY
LEADS ME TO A PULP SB TWO FORTY
FIVE BECAUSE THE BILL OFFERS
ABORTION TO POOR VULNERABLE
WOMEN AS A SIMPLE EASY ON. THE
TO UNPLANNED PREGNANCY BUT IT
IS THAT I WAS PREGNANT HOMELESS
HERETHE BUSH INDUSTRY WITH ALL
TOO HAPPY TO HELP ME OUT THE
DECISION TO TERMINATE AN UNBORN
HUMAN LIFE IS OFTEN TAKEN MORE
LIGHTLY THAN BUYING A CAR A
PLASTIC SURGEON PROBABLY TAKES
MORE CARE TO INFORM THE PATIENT
OF THE DETAILED A LONG TERM
EFFECTS ON THE ABORTIONIST. IT
WAS LOW COOLING DOWN PERIOD AND
NO DEPTH DISCLOSURE OF THE
POSSIBLE EFFECTS WHAT ABOUT IS
ACTUALLY BEING DONE A BOARD
MEMBER OF PLAN PARENTHOOD
SUGGESTED THAT REGRETTABLE OF A
SIGN OF MENTAL ILLNESS. HELLO
RESPONSE TO BE SIMILAR TO THE
SERVER I RECEIVED AFTER THE
ABORTION ARE PUSHED A BIT OUT
OF MY MIND IMMEDIATELY GRASP OF
THE REMEMBER IT WAS FILLED WITH
REGRET LATER I THOUGHT ON CHILD
PIECE FROM I REALIZED WOW IT
REALLY WASN'T. I FELT HARM
REGRET THE PAIN CONTINUED FOR
AND I HAD A DREAM THAT A THE
END WAS DAMP ON FALLOUT WILL
AWAKE THESE OCCASIONAL
INCIDENTS OF A AND BILL ME MORE
THE WASHINGTON THIS LIKE THE
PRODUCT. ON NO THAT FOR THE WHO
WHEN A WOMAN GETS PREGNANT SHE
HAD SPECIFICALLY MEET THEIR
PORTION INDUSTRY HAS NORTH. FOR
THAT THE MOTHER KNOW THAT THE
IS A REAL BABY WHAT I WILL IT
WAS A REAL OUR INTO. EMOTIONAL
TO IS WHAT SB TWO BIBLE FOR TO
PAY FOR TO REASON PLEASE BOTH
KNOW AND TWO FOUR FIVE STRONG
OPPOSE. IN OPPOSITION AND SB
TWO FORTY FIVE. YES MY NAME IS
GREG BIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND- I THINK WITH ANOTHER
WITNESS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS JONATHAN
KELLER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY ALLIANCE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING A NO VOTE ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SAY NO ONE
ELSE UP IN THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO PEOPLE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY FIVE
AND REMINDER AGAIN ITS NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND TO
SHOW OPPOSITION HONEST HONESTY
TO FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IN OUR FIRST
PARTISAN IS ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WIND FIFTY
FIVE YOUR OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR.
THIRTY FIVE. HELLO YES PLEASE
IN NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLEASE. I'M SORRY YEAH A LITTLE
10% K- SEVERAL COUNSELOR AND I
STRONGLY THIS BILL. Q. NEXT
LINE. EXURBAN NINETY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. BY NINETY TWO PLEASE
ON YOU. WE'RE TRYING TO A.
NINETY TWO. THIS IS A JACKSON I
AM AND- CONCERN IT'S. YEAH CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES I HEAR YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE. MY NAME IS
DEBORAH ASTRONOMICAL CITIZEN
OPPOSED AB TWO FORTY FIVE. HE'S
VERY MUCH AN EXCELLENT.
EXTRALITE NINETY FIVE YOUR OPEN.
MANY HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE OF FOR YOU ARE
OPEN YES THIS IS LISA POPCORN
AND WILL IMPACT WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE HELLO THIS IS SILVA AND I
WITH BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE FIFTY YOU ARE. YES THIS IS
WHEN IT STILL. A SERVICE
DIRECTOR OF CAL. FOR LIFE IN
WHICH OF S. TWO FOUR FIVE THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. BY NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE SAID HIS
ACTION SOME COUNCIL I JUST
OPPOSE. THANK YOU EXLINE. PINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE CALL. HI
THIS IS TONY ROAD WITH CAPITAL
RESOURCES STRONG. THANK THANKS.
WHAT WILL I WILL TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT. BY THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
ON YOU. LEVINE THIS IS MERRY
CALL- RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THIS SB TWO
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU EXLINE.
TWENTY ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TO GIVE YOU THE NUMBER.
OKAY ARE OPEN. ONE ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT
BYRD I AM AN ORGANIZER WITH
COLLECTIONS IS STILL AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF DISTRICTS ELEVEN I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB TWO
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANK YOU AND EXPLAIN WILL GO
TO IS ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB. TWO FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR EXCITED
GOING TO STATE YOUR NAME MA'AM.
OKAY NEXT TIME WE WILL TRY ONE
OH NINE AGAIN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MELISSA GRAHAM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE AREA AND I
pNEXT LINE. AND AGAIN IF THERE
ARE ANY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY FIVE
ONE MOMENT THE STRUCTURE. A
COUPLE MORE QUEUING UP. I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT WAS OPERATORS
GIVEN THEIR LINE NUMBER OKAY.
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M REALISTIC ABOUT
HUMAN I'M NOT ONE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IF
THEY ARE READY TO IT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE MOMENT
I THINK WE HAD TO MARK YOUR.
OKAY SOMEBODY DID JUST QUEUE UP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
STRUCTURE ISSUE WITH THIS
MOMENTARILY. OKAY AND WE WILL
GO TO ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HELLO YES PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION SESSION HELLO
THANK YOU. HELLO JENNIFER
BARRON ROSEVILLE RESIDENCE
LATINO AN ACTUAL LOW INCOME
MOTHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN. THEY CAN SHARE I
APOLOGIZE- RIGHT SPENT ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
WILL BE G. U. I AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE QUALITY RIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. I WILL NOT USE THAT
COUNT THAT TIME AGAINST THE
OPPOSITION. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S NOW BRING IT TO
THE COMMITTEE I WILL MENTION
THAT WE DO HAVE. SOMEONE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT SUBURBAN
ANALYSIS- AVAILABLE SO WITH
THAT I SEE A CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANNA THANK US SENATOR CONSOLES
FOR BRINGING THE MEASURE
FORWARD AND I'M HAPPY TO BE A-
CIBLE JOINT AUTHOR. IT'S ONE TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE THINGS- THE
FIRST OPPOSITION WITNESS CALLED
THE BILL SEXIST. I DON'T KNOW
HOW COULD BE SEXIST WHEN ONLY
WOMEN CAN GET PREGNANT I DON'T
THINK A MAN CAN HAVE AN
ABORTION. THEN I ALSO ALWAYS
WANT TO CORRECT FOLKS WHO
REFERRED TO THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY THERE IS NO ABORTION
INDUSTRY. ABORTION IS A MEDICAL
PROCEDURE PERFORMED BY A DOCTOR
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE IT AND
NO ONE IS ASKING YOU PERSONALLY
TO HAVE AN ABORTION. BUT THIS
BILL MAKE SURE THAT WOMEN WHO
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE HAVE IT
PAID FOR AND IT IS NOT. ANOTHER
OBSTACLE FOR THEM SO I AM HAPPY
TO SUPPORT AND WILL VOTE. ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU. CENTER
WIENER. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIRMAN ALL RIGHTS SUPPORT-
BILL IT'S A STRONG MOVE TOWARDS
NOT CHEST REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
ACCESS IN NAME BUT REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH ACCESS IN PRACTICE AND
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY WE HAD THIS GROUND
BREAKING RULING AND NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE TO THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT WOMEN HAVE AN ABSOLUTE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN BODIES AND MAKE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES. OVER THE YEARS
IT'S A GRADUAL CHIPPING AWAY TO
SIT OKAY WELL YOU HAVE THIS
RIGHT ON PAPER. BUT WE'RE JUST
GOING TO MAKE IT HARDER AND
HARDER AND HARDER FOR YOU TO
ACTUALLY EXERCISE IT. TO THE
POINT WHERE THERE ARE STATES
WHERE THEY MIGHT THERE MIGHT
ONLY BE ONE OR TWO PROVIDERS IN
THE ENTIRE STATE WHO PERFORM
ABORTION SERVICES. AND SO
PARTICULARLY IF YOU ARE A LOWER
INCOME- ONE MAN OR SOMEONE WHO
SIMPLY CAN'T TAKE TIME TO
TRAVEL SIX HOURS YOU CAN
ACCESS. ABORTION SERVICES WE
SHOULD BE GOING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION. I CALIFORNIA I'M
BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS- TO
WOMEN NOT BEING ABLE TO
ABSOLUTELY CONTROL THEIR OWN
BODIES AND THEIR OWN LIVES AND
NOT HAVE OTHER PEOPLE MAKE
THOSE CHOICES. FOR THEM- AND WE
KNOW THAT IT HEALTHCARE IN
GENERAL- COPAYS AND- I DID.
ALTHOUGH THIS AND NOT. WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THEM GENERALLY. CAN
HAVE PROFOUNDLY NEGATIVE
IMPACTS. IN TERMS OF COST
BURDENS AND WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW A FIVE DOLLAR
COPAY. WHEN YOU GO TO PICK UP
MEDICINE AT THE STORE AT THE
PHARMACY THIS CAN BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT COST SHARING
REQUIREMENTS THAT. THAT'S JUST
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM ACCESSING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES SO
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ODD
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND
I'LL BE GOING ON. THANK YOU THE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES
CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. SO WE HAVE. I THINK
ALL WE HAVE A- I THINK CERTAIN
THINGS COME TO MIND WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT HEALTH CARE WHAT IS
HEALTH CARE IT'S GETTING CANCER
TREATMENT IT'S GETTING YOUR
COVERED TESTING IT GETTING YOUR
EYES EXAMINED IT'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS ONE OF THE THINGS IT
DOES NOT COME TO MY MIND. IS AN
ELECTIVE SURGERY THAT TAKES THE
LIFE OF ANOTHER HUMAN BEING SO
I'M NOT CERTAIN WHY THE
ANALYSIS CONTINUES TO REFER TO
ABORTION AS HEALTH CARE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT HEALTH CARE IT'S AN
ELECTIVE SURGERY- IT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT IS AN ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARY AND JUST LIKE IF
SOMEONE. GOES TO- HAVE THEIR
NOSE FIXED- LASER EYE SURGERY
OR YOU KNOW PICK SOME OTHER
TYPE OF ELECTIVE SURGERY HAVE
TO PAY FOR IT THERE ARE CERTAIN
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH GETTING
THAT TYPE OF SURGERY BECAUSE IT
IS AN ELECTIVE SURGERY. SAID
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
BURDENS THIS STATE HAS
EXPERIENCED JUST OVER THE LAST
YEAR NOT TO MENTION IN. YOU
KNOW PREVIOS YEARS IN THE
FUTURE OF. THE TYPES OF THINGS
WE WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR AND
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR THEM. ALL
REASONABLE COSTS- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD THE AS A
STATE SHOULD BE FORCING PEOPLE
TO PAY FOR SERVICES THAT THEY
ONLY AND DON'T AGREE WITH
EITHER FROM A MORAL OR
RELIGIOUS SPACE PERSPECTIVE.
BUT ALSO SHOULDN'T BE FORCED TO
PAY FOR- THERE'S A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY AND
THAT COMES ALONG AND I THINK IF
SOMEONE MAKES- THE CHOICE. TO
HAVE AN ABORTION THAT IS THEIR
CHOICE BY LAW BUT I DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD BE MAKING IT- I
FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
THAT CHOICE BECAUSE AGAIN. THIS
IS AN ELECTIVE SURGERY- THIS IS
THIS IS DOES NOT FALL UNDER THE
CATEGORY- OF HEALTH CARE IS WE
ORDINARILY WOULD CONSIDER IT SO
I- WOULD REQUEST A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
MELENDEZ ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAYING NONE AYE I WOULD- I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY FIRST OF
ALL AND I HAVE BEEN AND I WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THE STATEMENT
THAT BUSH IS NOT HEALTHCARE IT
IS HEALTH CARE AS A PHYSICIAN I
WILL SAY THAT IT IS HEALTH
CARE- THERE'S A ROLE FOR COST
SHARING. THE RAND- INSURANCE
STUDIES SHOWED THAT. BUT
THEY'RE ALSO PLACES WHERE
CARSHARING DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
AND- WITHOUT ELABORATING ON A
WHOLE LIST OF THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT IN FACT
ACTUALLY WE DON'T HAVE COST
SHARING FOR PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES THERE'S- FOR OTHER
TYPES OF. HIS AS WELL AND IN MY
MIND I ALSO THINK THAT- COST
SHARING FOR. THIS FORM OF
HEALTH CARE- PORTION SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE TIME
ISSUES AS WELL- THAT SAID THAT.
THAT THE PATIENTHAS TO DEAL
WITH- IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND-
AND I THINK IT DID. BECAUSE AND
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS SO WITH
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- CENTER GONZALEZ WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK OUR CO
SPONSORS- ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO CALLED AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THEIR- EFFORTS IN
THIS AND CONTINUING TO BE OF A
LOUD VOICE FOR- WHAT I'LL SAY
ISN'T. EVENFURTHER HEALTH CARE
EQUITY FOR. WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS IS WHY MANY
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS LIKE
MY OWN AND IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH OF CREATED. BLACK
MATERNAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT- WOMEN OF
COLOR ESPECIALLY BLACK MOTHERS
ARE FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
PASS AWAY FROM PREGNANCY.
RELATED CAUSES THAN WHITE
MOTHERS THEY SUFFER FROM LOWER
BIRTH RATES. ARE LOWER- BIRTH
WEIGHTS AND WE NEED TO DO MORE
IN THIS SPACE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE PROTECTED ALL THE WAY
AROUND AND THAT THEY DON'T-
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
THEIR- ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH FREEDOMS. SO WITH THAT I
ASK THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND THINK AGAIN OUR
SPONSORS. THANK YOU A IS THERE
A MOTION ON THE BILL. OKAY
CENTER LAY ALL RIGHT SO THE
BILL'S BEEN VICE. LEYVA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MAY. AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AND I THINK YOU
DID SAY YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS RIGHT. YES YES OKAY.
SO DO PASSED AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN HI MELINDA NO. MELINDA'S NO
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE AND SALAS
I GONZALEZ I GREW. ROOF NO HER
TITLE. LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
LIMóN. ROTH IRA ROTH AYE RUBIO.
WIENER FIVE WIENER HI HAVE
SWITCHED. THANKS TO. THE ROLES
CURRENTLY SIXTY TWO- WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
THE NEXT ITEM IS- ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. AND THAT'S SB FOR A TO
BUY CENTER HER TADO- WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT AT YOUR DESK. YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
SEPT IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN RESPONSE TO THE
POLICY COMMENT IN THE ANALYSIS.
B. IN THESE AMENDMENTS ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
NOTIFIED IN ADVANCE OF A PILOT
PROGRAM TAKEN EFFECT. SB FOUR
ZERO TWO DIRECT HEALTHCARE
PAYERS PURCHASERS PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS AND HEALTH CARE
CONSUMER REPRESENTATIVES TO
COME TO THE TABLE UNDER THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. TO COLLABORATE ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF MULTI PAYER
PAYMENT REFORM PILOTS FOR
CERTAIN FEE FOR SERVICE PRIMARY
CARE PRACTICES. THERE IS
GROWING EVIDENCE THAT INVESTING
IN PRIMARY CARE PROMOTES HEALTH
EQUITY IMPROVES PATIENT
OUTCOMES AND EXPERIENCES.
INCREASES THE SUPPLY OF PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS AND REDUCES
HEALTHCARE SPENDING. AN
ADEQUATE ACCESS. HAS BEEN
FUELED BY PROVIDER CARE PAYMENT
MODEL THAT IS NOT STRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT AND CANNOT SUSTAIN A
COMPREHENSIVE PRIMARY CARE
SYSTEM WHICH IS PATIENT
CENTERED COORDINATED
COMPREHENSIVE IN VALUE BASED.
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
PRACTICES STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN
FINANCIAL VIABILITY WITHOUT
THEM MARKET POWER AND RESOURCES
HELD BY THEIR LARGER
COUNTERPARTS. CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
RESIDENTS OFTEN HAVE TO TRAVEL
FARTHER FOR CARE THAN THEIR
URBAN COUNTERPARTS. IF THE COST
TO OPERATE BECOMES TOO MUCH FOR
THESE PRACTICES THEY USE. TO
BEAR AND THEY ARE FORCED TO
CLOSE. THE DISTANCE WILL
INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY. SUCH
PRACTICES ARE LOCATED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA BUT IN
SMALLER RURAL AREAS LIKE THOSE
OF MY DISTRICT. THEY ARE
SOMETIMES THE CLOSEST OR ONLY
PROVIDERS THAT USE THEM SB FOUR
ZERO TWO SIX TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO CARE IN AREAS HIT HARDEST BY
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BY
GETTING PATIENTS PROVIDERS AND
PAYERS TOGETHER TO FORM A MULTI
PAYER PAYMENT REFORM
COLLABORATIVE. IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES PILOT PROGRAMS THATMOVE SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
BEFORE SERVICE PRIMARY CARE.
MEDICAL PRACTICES TO
SUSTAINABLE VALUE BASED PAYMENT
MODELS. TODAY HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ARE JOINING US
REMOTELY DR SAMANTA READY
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN. AND
KATRINA REYES VICE PRESIDENT OF
ADVOCACY AND POLICY FOR
CALIFORNIA CAN BE A FAMILY
PHYSICIANS. THANK YOU CENTER
TADO MODERATE PLEASE BRING
UNTIL DR SAMANTA READY AND
CAPPED AT KATERINA RADIUS- TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH
TWO AND JUST A REMINDER TO THE
WITNESSES- YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
APIECE FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES TOGETHER. YOUR LINES
ARE OPEN PLEASE ON MUTE ON YOUR
END. DOCTOR READY ARE YOU
PREPARE TO INTERACT. THANK YOU.
PLEASE BE ON. THANK YOU DR TAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE UP THE TO
SPEAK IN YOU TO DOLLARS FOR
OFFERING THE SIMPLE BILL MY
NAME IS MINOR RIGHT AND I THE
FAMILY WHO PRACTICALLY SALINA
SPENT A LOT TWENTY YEARS I
FOUND IN THE SMALL WHO PRACTICE
ENTIRELY IN THE OF THE HIGH. IN
BECAUSE ALL THE OTHER BINDING
AND IS THAT TO ME OUR NEEDS WE
PROVIDED CARE TO OUR ACTORS AND
OTHER MORE MARCH COMMUNITIES
FROM THE AT THAT INCLUDE
MEDICARE AND IMAGE. FROM MY
PRACTICE AND OTHERS LIKE THAT
IF YOU FOR THREE PAYMENT LAW WE
MESSED UP A UNDER VERY TO WRECK
THE. ADVANCED PRIMARY CARE WORK
WE DO. IN ADDITION WE STRUGGLE
DAILY THE ANYTHING. AND LYFT
PATIENT CREATE BY IN. DEMANDS
OF MULTIPLE PAIRS. INCLUDING
THEIR MORE FOR REQUIRED BILLING.
QUALITY HOLDEN NINETEEN WERE IN
THE- MONTEREY COUNTY HAS BEEN
VERY BASED ON OUR EXIT.
POPULATION WOULD LONELY AND
SYSTEM. IN MY PRACTICAL WITHOUT
IT MIGHT IN EARLY DAYS DEPEND.
FOR THE EIGHT TELL PATIENTS
WOULD LOSE THAT TO CARE AND
THERE ARE MANY OTHER. FOR
SERVICES A GOOD FOR. CARE
TAKING TO COURT A PAGE CARE A-
INDIVIDUALS KEEP THEM WELL AWAY
ON ME PRETTY AND SERVICES. MANY
THE THERE'S A FISH WITH US.
RECOGNITION AND- NEED TO BE
PROVIDED TO THE WORK THAT KEEPS
PATIENTS HEALTHY. IT MARKAKIS
RESULT IN BETTER THAT AND THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND WE YEARS
I BEEN APPROACH BY HEART. WITH
TO SELL MY PRODUCT TO THEM. THE
ME THEY HAVE WARM POWER THAT IF
I ACROSS THAT WOULD INCREASE
COSTS TO OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
STRONG PRIMARY LEAD IMPROVED.
IN CLASS STATING WE NEED TO
START TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE
KNOWN FOR. AND HE WILL TO DO SO
ABOUT IT. PARTICULARLY IN A HIT
HARD BY CO NINETY. THIS BILL
TAKE THE- FIRST STEP THE
GETTING A- ON AND PUT IN FLAT A
MOVETO WITHOUT BASED. I
CRACKED IN MY- CAN'T WAIT
LONGER. THANK YOU. DURING THE
QUARTER SILVA WILL CREATE THE
FOUNDATION FOR TRANSFORMING
PRIMARY CARE. LIKE A GOOD OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM PRIMARY CARE
WE CAN PROMOTE HEALTH EQUITY
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
PATIENT EXPERIENCE INCREASES BY
FIVE MAJOR PROVIDERS AND REDUCE
COSTS. THE SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
AND ACCESS PRIMARY AND
PREVENTIVE CARE IT WITH THE FOR
SERVICE MODEL WHICH IS NOT
STRUCTURED THE COURT OR
SOMETHING A COMPREHENSIVE
PRIMARY CARE SYSTEM. IF YOU
WANT TO CARRY THE CASE IN
REGION'S WORKSHOP PRIMARY CARE
PRACTICE MIGHT BE THE ONLY
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE CARE.
THE PILOT CREATED BY THE- WITH
ONLINE PAYMENT METHODS QUALITY
MEASURES IN. THE NEW WITH THE
COURT BOB OVERALL CRIME CARE
FOR. THAT WE CAN NO AWAY FROM
FOR SERVICE PAYMENT. TOWARD THE
BY BASED PAYMENT MODEL THAT
PROMOTE PATIENT CENTERED
COURTNEY KERR. AND AFTER CARE.
COORDINATED EFFORTS TO BUILD A
STRONG CARE COUNTY HAS PROVEN
RESULTS. IN A PRIMARY PAYMENT
DELIVERY IN THIS FLOOD RIGHT
INSURANCE YOU SCHOOL. AFP IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN DISTRICT STATE
NEARLY ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HEALTH. AND PATIENTS THAT. WHEN
YOU'RE AFTER LUNCH. SIGNATURE
CONTINUES EXPAND OKAY WITHIN
THE MARIN THOUGHT. INTO THEIR
STATE THAT AS RHODE ISLAND IN
OREGON. THE DAILY THE CRITICAL
PART LOCAL FEAR PAYMENT REFORM
EFFORTS BECAUSE IT IS USUALLY
MAKE THE CONDITION TODAY RIGHT
THE. AIR MARCH THIRTY CONSUMERS
TO PLAN IMPLEMENT PAYMENT WITH
KILEY. THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE A
AND OVERALL CARE CHANGE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THE FOR THE COURT
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH- NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SOME.
OF S. FOUR OH TWO. LET'S MOVE
TO THE GALLERY SCENE ON PUBLIC
GALLERY OVED ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEN ON TWENTY. MODERATOR OPEN
THE OLD TELEPHONE LINE FOR
PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BEFORE- OH TWO
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. FINALLY TWENTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON RONALD
KOEMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PENITENTIARY HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. SIX WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU EXLINE. ONE ONE
NINETEEN YOU ARE UP. RESIDENS
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
SPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANKS TO A LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CAITLYN JENNER MANAGE FOR THEIR
MEDICAL DO NOT FOR A UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND HELP QUALITY
CALLING ON THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR OH TWO AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU OUT CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CRYING CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. MISTER I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOVES
TO OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR OH TWO
WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD UP
OPPOSITION FOR- TESTAMENT
WITNESS FOR TESTIMONY SO. WILL
THEN MOVE ON TO- PEOPLE WAY TO
DATE OR NAME OR STATION
POSITION OR SOME OF THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SAYING NOT PUBLIC
EITHER LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE WITH
TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO PASS BEFORE- TO
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
AND TO SHOW OPPOSITION IN- THIS
ARMS AS BEFORE- TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU. AGAIN ONE
ZERO SOCIAL OPPOSITION ON S.
BEFORE- TO. MISTER CARE NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP OKAY SAYING THE-
THIRTY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ARE
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES CENTER
EGGMAN. I WOULD JUST AS THE
THINKCENTRE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE WE KNOW.
OVERDOSES EPIDEMIC AND
ESPECIALLY IN OUR RURAL PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT THAT
SAME AGE GROUP WHO TENDS TO USE
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES WITH
THAT I'D MOVE THE BILL OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN FROM
MOVING THE BILL. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SAYING
NONE OF US ARE TODD- I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE COME UP WITH-
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE ENSURING
WE HAVE A SUFFICIENT FINANCING
SYSTEM SUPPORT THAT. AND SELL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. BANK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
OKAY SO THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER EGGMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN I AM THE LONDON SIDE
MELENDEZ AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AIKEN SALAS. AND SALAS I GREW-
TADA TIME FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA I LEóN ROTH HI ROTH AYE
RUBIO. WIENER WIENER HI. YEAH
OKAY THE ROLES KILEY EIGHT ZERO
OPEN HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT SB SIX
FOUR FOUR BY CENTER LABEL YOU
PRESENT FROM YOUR DESK
EXCELLENT- SO PLEASE BEGIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SB SIX FORTY
FOUR WILL ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT EDT TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH COVERED
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSE OF
OUT REACH ON HEALTH COVERAGE
OPTIONS. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS EDT
TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
ALMOST THREE DOZEN STATE AGENCY
AGENCIES AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AGENCIES IN OTHER
STATES BUT THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
COVERED CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CONDUCTING OUTREACH
ON AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SB SIX FORTY FOUR
WOULD CHANGE THAT BY ALONE EDT
TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
COVERED CALIFORNIA FOR THIS
EXACT PURPOSE AND WILL ALSO
PROTECT PRIVACY BY ENSURING
THIS INFORMATION STAY WITH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. IF COVER
CALIFORNIA HAD CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR ALL
UNEMPLOYMENT APPLICANTS THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONDUCT
PROACTIVE AND TARGETED OUTREACH
TO A POPULATION THAT WOULD MOST
LIKELY BENEFIT FROM INFORMATION
ON COVERAGE INCLUDING BOTH
COVERED CALIFORNIA AND MEDIC
CAL AS WE ALL KNOW HERE IN
AMERICA JOBS AND HEALTH
INSURANCE FOR OFTENTIMES
CLOSELY LINKED IF A PERSON
LOSES THEIR JOB THEIR
OFTENTIMES FACED BY LOSING
THEIR HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
BOTH THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS LED TO AN
UNPRECEDENTED JOB LOSS AND
DROPS IN INCOME. BUT DESPITE
THE SIGNIFICANT JOB LOSSES AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC BOTH
MEDIC CAL AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAVE EXPERIENCED
LOWER THAN EXPECTED ENROLLMENT
THE LATEST MEDICARE WON'T COVER
CALIFORNIA DATA SUGGESTS THAT
SOME CALIFORNIANS ARE CHOOSING
TO GO WITHOUT COVERAGE OR NOT
GETTING CONNECTED WITH THE BEST
COVERAGE OPTIONS IN SHORT THIS
BILL WILL IMPROVE CALIFORNIANS
ACCESS TO HEALTH INSURANCE
WELLS AVOID COSTLY AND
DANGEROUS GAPS IN THEIR CARE
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS
RONALD. COLEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HELLO THE
WORK AND DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH
ACCESS MEMBERS WHEN APPROPRIATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR LEYVA- JUST
ONE QUICK QUESTION BEFORE WE
BRING THE WITNESSES SUPPORT I
BELIEVE THERE TO AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
WHICH WE- BELIEVE THAT YOU YOU
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING UP THE
EX COMMITTEE. HAVING TO DO WITH
ONE PRIVACY ENCRYPTION INTO
JUST OBTAINING THE CONSENT OF
THE APPLICANT ARE YOU ARE
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
THAT THAT IS CORRECT MISTER
CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT NO PROBLEM.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT SO- MODERATOR PLEASE
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE THAT
RONALD COLEMAN FROM C. PAN AND
DIANA DOUGLAS FROM HEALTH
ACCESS. I EACH OF YOU HAVE UP
TO TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES TOGETHER FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH- RONALD COLMAN.
MISTER COLEMAN LIKE SHOULD BE
OPEN PLEASE ON MUTE ON YOUR END.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RONALD COLEMAN EACH
YEAR ON BEHALFOF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNOT THINK
HEALTHCARE WORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT MEDICAL SPONSOR SB SIX
FOUR FOUR BY SENATOR LENA WHICH
WILL HELP ENSURE INDIVIDUALS
ARE CONNECTED TO HEALTH.
COVERAGE OPTIONS AT A TIME THEY
MAY NEED IT THE MOST. THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND LEAD TO
UNPRECEDENTED JOB LOSS IN DROPS
IN INCOME WITH EDP REPORTING
THAT ONE POINT THREE MILLION
MORE CALIFORNIANS FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT SURE. WITH THE
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR YOUNGER
AND LESS EDUCATED WORKERS
EXPERIENCING DISPROPORTIONATE
RATES OF JOB LOSS IN THE STATE.
THE COSBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SHOWS THAT WE HAVE NO TIME TO
WASTE AND ENSURING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES DON'T
SLIP THROUGH OUR HEALTH CARE
SAFETY NET. AB SEAT AND WE KNOW
LOSS OF JOB BASED HEALTH
COVERAGE CAN EXACERBATE
DISPARITIES AND LEAD TO POOR
HEALTH OUTCOMES DUE TO CULVERT
NINETEEN RELATED ILLNESS OR
OTHER DELAYED CARE. THE SAME
COMMUNITIES ARE MOST LIKELY TO
BE UNINSURED BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND DUE TO SYSTEMIC
RACISM INEQUALITY BASED.
DIABETES AND OTHER CONDITIONS
AT HIGHER RATES DUE TO
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE JOBS AND HOUSING
CONDITIONS WE BELIEVE LOSING
YOUR JOB SHOULD NOT
AUTOMATICALLY MEAN LOSING YOUR
HEALTH CARE ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
CAN ENSURE OUR STATE AGENCIES
SHARE INFORMATION. IN ORDER TO
CONNECT PEOPLE WITH COVERAGE
OPTIONS BETTER RIGHT FOR THEM.
SB SIX FOUR FOUR WILL ENSURE
PEOPLE ARE CONNECTED THE
COVERAGE THROUGH CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
MARKETING OUTREACH ENROLLMENT
ASSISTANCE INCLUDING FROM
TRUSTED COMMUNITY BASED
NAVIGATOR. AT A CRITICAL TIME
WHEN THEY NEED IT THE MOST FOR
THOSE REASONS WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY. ASK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
DIA DE. AND TEACH LAW YOU TO
MINUTES AND OF THE FORTY. FOUR
SECONDS. THANK YOU DON'T USE
ALL THE TIME IN THE CHURCH CARE
AND BACK. UPDATED LOOK PERFECT.
YES THE STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE
CONSUMER ADVOCATE COALITION
HERE IS A CO SPONSOR OF SB SIX
FORTY FOUR. THANKS TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT LOSING YOUR
JOB NO LONGER MEANS THAT YOU
HAVE TO REMAIN UNINSURED.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICAL OR ABOUT EIGHTY NOT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND ALSO
COVERED CALIFORNIA HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE. WHICH
IS WHAT THE NATION IN
AFFORDABILITY. HOWEVER ONE OF
THE BIGGEST REMAINING HURDLE TO
COVERAGE BESIDES AFFORDABILITY
IS LACK OF AWARENESS OF YOUR
COVERAGE OPTIONS. ESPECIALLY IF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE TRANSITIONS
EMPLOYMENT INCOME MANY ARE
UNAWARE OF WHAT THEIR BEST
COVERAGE OPTIONS ARE OR EVEN
WHERE TO TURN FOR AT THE-
START. RIGHT NOW PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
FROM EATING WITH THE WEATHER
CHECK THE NOTICE FROM COVERED
CALIFORNIA ON THEIR INSURANCE
OPTIONS. HOWEVER IT SHOULD BE
NOTED TAT THIS IS ONLY FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE RECEIVING
BENEFITS AND ONLY ONCE THEY'VE.
ACTUALLY STARTED TO GET THE
BENEFIT. ANYMORE PEOPLE TO
EIGHTY BUT OUR I COVER. OR WANT
RECEIVE A- SO THEY'RE NOT
RECEIVING THESE NOTICE THAT.
MEANWHILE FOR NOT COVERED.
GREATEST SHE- ACT MARKETING
CAPABLE AND INVOLVEMENT PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW WE ARE
MAKING THE- AND EAT EDT A NOT
ABLE TO SHARE. INFORMATION
COPPER CALIFORNIA. SB SIX FORTY
FOUR ONE SURE THAT COVERED
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED BASIC
INFORMATION FOR ALL APPLICANTS
TO EDT PROGRAMS INCLUDING
UNEMPLOYMENT AND FBI. BUT BOTH
OF THOSE WHO HAVE OFTEN THOUGHT
THAT THEIR BENEFITS OR WHO HAVE
HAD THEIR WORK HOURS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED. ITS ONLY
WILL COVER CALIFORNIA TO REACH
OUT TO THOSE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING EMPLOYMENT
TRANSITION TO MAKE THEM AWARE
OF ALL THEIR OPTIONS. AND ALSO
NOTABLY THE MEDIC CALLUM
COVERED CALIFORNIA USED THE
SAME APPLICATION IT WILL SERVE
THE DUAL PURPOSE OF CONNECTING
PEOPLE AND NOT A CAL AS WELL.
SB SIX FORTY FOUR WILL GO A
LONG WAY IN PREVENTING
DANGEROUS GAPS IN HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR MAKING SURE PEOPLE
ARE INFORMED OF THEIR OPTIONS
EXACTLY WHEN THEY'RE MOST
VULNERABLE. FOR THESE REASONS
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB SIX
FORTY FOUR AND RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR I THOUGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WITH THE LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE A WITNESS. AND
OF S. B. SIX FOUR NAY OR IS A-
AND DOES ONLY MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC. SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY THIS REMOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEN ON ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT AND SB SIX FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY TO START.
GOOD AFTERNOON GENTLE OR A ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BIANCA
BLOOM QUEST WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EXLINE.
THANKS WILL GO TO ONE EIGHTY
SIX. BRANDON MARCHING AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN COURT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE SIXTY SIX EUROPE. HELLO
SENATOR PANNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JENNIFER MALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THANKS TO OPEN UP
ONE ONE THIRTY FIVE. HELLO THIS
IS WHAT IT WILL COVER WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANK YOU THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOUR FOUR AND WE WILL GO
ONLINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CATHERINE CALLING FROM
THE NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THE WHO SHALL DEAL ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN FORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND MR
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL NOW MOVES TO- TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FOUR FOUR
WE HAVE NO ONE WHO HAS
REGISTERED TO PROVIDE LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. SO THAT-WILL THEN MOVE TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX FOUR FOUR UP IN THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE KNOWN AT THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
THROUGH IN TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FOUR FOUR
AGAINST NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. THANK YOU MR SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION ON SB SIX FOUR
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FOUR FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS GIVING UP HIS
CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU- LET'S NOW
TAKE IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SAID
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF THE FIRST FIVE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND ALSO
INAPPROPRIATE I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IN THE
PAST YEAR- AND I KNOW I'M NOT
ALONE- MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
INUNDATED WITH CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS REALLY STRUGGLING
FOR RESOURCES. ANYWHERE FROM
HOUSING TO FOOD AND HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO BE VERY MINDFUL THAT
WHEN PEOPLE LOSE THEIR JOBS
IT'S NOT JUST THEIR JOB THEY'RE
LOSING IT IS THE RESOURCE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THEIR
HEALTH CARE BUT ALSO MORE
IMPORTANT THEIR PEACE OF MIND
THERE IS A PEACE OF MIND
KNOWING THAT YOU ARE COVERED
AND SO I KNOW THAT THIS BILL
DOES A GREAT JOB AND
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND JUST MAKING IT
EASIER FOR THEM. SO WITHOUT A I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND
I ALSO ASK FOR A NOVEL THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER RUBIO CIRCLES
AULUS. YES I TO JUST WANNA COME-
THE AUTHOR FOR. THIS BILL TO
REALLY SMART BILL WE OFTEN
DON'T THINK OF HOW WE CAN MAKE
GOVERNMENT A BIT MORE EFFICIENT
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS REALLY
CHALLENGING TIME WHERE. SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN NEED I AGREE AND
I'VE EVEN ASKED MY OWN OFFICE.
TO START TALKING ABOUT OTHER
PROGRAMS A BIT MORE- WITHIN OUR
OWN INTERNAL- OPERATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY. THAT
TOUCHES EDT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO KNOW OF ALL THE VAST
BENEFITS WE HAVE HERE IN THE
STATE AND HOW THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM AND IT'S
REALLY TOUGH TIME. SO IT THAT
WOULD ALSO LOVE TO BE OUT-
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK HERE.
AND OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON SB SIX FOUR FOUR
SAYING NONE I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT I ALSO CONCUR WITH- BOTH A
CENTERS RUBIO AND GONZALEZ- IN
THEIR SUPPORT AND- AND SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF THANK YOU FOR
THE NICE COMMENTS AND I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT- TO SENATOR
CONSOLES AS POINT WHEN THIS WAS
BROUGHT TO ME I SAID WHAT DO
YOU MEAN WE DON'T ALREADY DO
THIS. SO IT'S- IT SEEMS LIKE A
SIMPLE THING BUT WE THINK THAT
IT WILL REALLY HELP A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT HEALTH CARE THE
PEOPLE ARE JUST IN A REALLY BAD
WAY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND WE'LL BE HAPPY
TO ADD YOU AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SEN RUBIO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE
REFER. TO THE COMMITTEES ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
LINDA'S HI MELENDEZ AYE EGGMAN
HI EGGMAN I GONZALEZ HI AND
SALAS I GREW. FURTADO NINE
TOTAL AYE LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
LIMóN ROTH. ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER. WIENER HI.
NINE THE BILL'S CURRENTLY NINE
ZERO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU- ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB THREE THREE SIX
HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN BY THE- AT
THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST- SO WE ARE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB THREE A SIX SO SIR
MELENDEZ T. WISH TO TAKE THE
GAVEL OR AT LEAST FIGURATIVELY
CERTAINLY- WELCOMES SENATOR PAN
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL YOUR
FIRST BILL WHICH IS SB THREE
ZERO SIX. THANK YOU. AND I'M
CHAIR- MEMBER- SENATORS- WE ARE
AT A CRISIS POINT WHEN IT COMES
TO STD INFECTIONS THIS COUNTRY
SO WELL WE ARE CURRENTLY
BATTLING COVE IN NINETEEN-
ACTUALLY. FOR MANY YEARS WE'VE
BEEN SEEING A STEADY RISE AND
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
IN FACT THE CDC ESTIMATES THAT
ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE IN UNITED
STATES HAVE A SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE. AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALMOST SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION STD INFECTIONS REPORTED
AND RATES OF SYPHILIS CHLAMYDIA
AND GONORRHEA ARE UP FORTY
PERCENT. SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE SECOND
HIGHEST SYPHILIS RATES IN THE
NATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN
FACT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SURPLUS RATE AMONG WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE INCREASED BY
7100403% THIS STD CRISIS
AFFECTS COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA KELLY
CALIFORNIA YOUTH PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
OVER HALF OF ALL STDS IN THE
STATE ARE REPORTED AMONG YOUTH
AGES FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD. AFRICAN AMERICANS
ARE 5100% MORE LIKELY CONTRACT
HONORING CHLAMYDIA THAN A WHITE
COUNTERPARTS AND THESE
DISPARITIES ARE EXPECTED TO
WORSEN AS A RESULT OF THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ONE
OF THE HARDEST DATA POINTS. FOR
ME TO SQUARE HAS TO DO WITH THE
RATES OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS A
DISEASE I THOUGHT WE GOT RID OF
WITH THE VICTORIAN ERA. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE BABIES WERE
BORN WITH CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
IN CALIFORNIA AND 9100%
INCREASE FROM TWENTY TWELVE.
THAT YEAR THERE WERE TWENTY
STILLBIRTHS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
DISEASE. AND HALF OF CAN GIO
SYPHILIS CASES OCCUR BECAUSE OF
GAPS IN TESTING AND TREATMENT
DURING PRENATAL CARE THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CLOSE THAT GAP BY
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
SCREENINGS. THE BILL ALSO
INCREASE ACCESS TO STD
SCREENING AND TREATMENT BY
OPENING UP ACCESS TO THE FAMILY
PACK PROGRAM INCREASING THE USE
OF CALIFORNIA'S EXPEDITED
PARTNER THERAPY OPTION BY
PROVIDERS AND PHARMACISTS. FOR
MANY HIV COUNSELOR SAID
MILLER'S ADMINISTER RAPID STD
TESTS AND REQUIRING INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR HOME STD TESTS.
CALIFORNIA'S UNFORTUNATELY
LAGGED IN ENACTING
COMPREHENSIVE POLICIES TO
INCREASE ACCESS STD SCREENING
AND TREATMENT. AND THE PANDEMIC
HAS EXACERBATED STD RATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING WITH EVERYONE STAYING
AT HOME IN THE PAST YEAR CAN
YOU IMAGINE WHAT WILL BE
HAPPENING IN THE COMING YEAR.
SB THREE OH SIX TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S STD
CRISIS BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
STD CARE AND ALCOHOL WAY
ESPECIALLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I DO HAVE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- TO TESTIFY- NOR PEACE
WITH FLINT'S EXEC DIRECTOR OF
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT. AND DR WARD CARPENTER
CO DIRECTOR OF HEALTH SERVICES
AT. THE LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR PAN- WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT-
DOCTOR PAN WE WILL START WITH
THE FIRST WITNESS YOU MENTIONED
NEW NORTHEAST FLINT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT- MISTER MODERATOR COULD
YOU OPEN HER LINE PLEASE. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN JUST ON MUTE ON YOUR END.
YOU. COMMITTEE AND SHARED MEAN
IF THEIR BASIC PLAN IN GRAND
RAPIDS IN THE MARKET ALONG WITH
THE PRACTICAL ACTION PROJECT WE
ARE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION WITH OFFICES IN
LOS ANGELES AND OFTEN WITH THE
MISSION DEDICATED TO BLACK
WOMEN AND GIRLS I'VE BEEN A BIT
ORGANIZATION FOR OVER A DECADE
NOW AND FOR MY ENTIRE CAN YOU
HEAR THAT IN A QUIET CRISIS
IMPACTING PROPORTIONALLY ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTION RATES
THAT ARE AT THE HIGHEST POINT
IN THIRTY YEARS WHAT'S
COMMITTEE A RATE OF TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN PERCENT. UNDER WE
EMBRACE A 56% I'M GONNA.
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS INCREASED
NINE. PERCENT BETWEEN TWENTY
TWO TO SEVEN. THESE RATE ARE
JUST A- IMPACTED BLACK
TEENAGERS IN THE CLEARING. I
DON'T SEE THE RATES ARE
CLEARING THE COLD AND PUT YOU
KNOW THE ARTISTS DIFFERENT AND
WE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE YOUNG OF
COLOR. ISSUES SUCH ENCOURAGE
ACCESS HEALTH CARE LACK OF TO
MOBILITY FOR ALL COULD YOU
PLEASE TO SCO. COOLEY WE HAVE
TO COOL TO TALK THIS ISSUE. SB
REALISTICALLY BECOME THE TO
ADDRESSING THE RATE INCREASE
EXPANDING ACCESS THE L. G. LOW
INCOME KENYANS. I LOVE OTHER CA
COLLEGES NOT HELL TO PAY TO GET
CREATED TO. THE CURRY USE OF
PARTNER THE TREE. SOLUTION
HUSBAND SHE TO REDUCE THE RATE.
AND THE REST TESTING AND OTHER.
STRATEGIES AT HOME. A WELL AS
UPDATING THE PUBLIC TESTING PER.
FOR CRICKET PEOPLE. NOT
PARTICULARLY. GIVEN THAT THIS
PERCENT OF PEOPLE WITH
APPLICABLE STATE ARE FOLKS WHO
ARE. AND TO BE DIE OF COULD GET
A STUFF WITH THE TWENTY. THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES GUIDELINES
DEFINING THE LEARNING INCREASE
THE CONGENITAL SYPHILIS AND HIV
THE TWO THIRD TRIMESTER. THIS
IS AND CAN SHE MISSED WHY I'M
SORRY YOU ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME YOU HAVE ABOUT TEN SECONDS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO WRAP IT UP.
YEAH A RECOMMENDATION IN MY
LIQUID BULK CDPH BUT THEY ARE-
WHEN THEY ARE. GEOGRAPHIC
OCATIONS THAT IN WRITING AT
SEEKING OUT RESTAURANTS SO.
WITH THAT THE ACT AND I AM
ECSTATIC. COMMITTEE BOTH YAK SB
THREE OR- GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THE NEXT WHICH TO TEST IN
TO IS WARD CARPENTER CO
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH SERVICES LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER MISTER
MODERATE WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR DOCTOR WARD. BACK%
TO WORK PLEASE ON IT ON YOUR IN
YOUR OPEN. AND DOCTOR WHERE YOU
HAD TWO MINUTES AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
DR WORK CARPENTER IS A SAID ON
THE CO DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
SERVICES AT THE LOS ANGELES ON
DEC CENTER. WHERE OVERSEE THE
HEALTHCARE OF OVER TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND LOW INCOME LGBT AND
HIV POSITIVE PATIENTS ANNUALLY.
AND A BOARD ERTIFIED INTERNIST
AND HIV SPECIALISTS HAVE
PERSONALLY CARED FOR THOUSANDS
OF PATIENTS OVER MY CAREER.
INCLUDING A STRONG FOCUS ON THE
TREATMENT AND PREVENTION STDS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF SB THREE OH SIX THE SP
COVERAGE IN CARE ACT. AND TO
THANK SENATOR PAN FOR
SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCES
ACCESS TO CARE. WE LEARNED JUST
YEAR THE POWER IN. FOR THE
BIGGER PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE
TO AN EPIDEMIC. AND A CRITICAL
ELEMENT OF LOW BARRIER ACCESS
TO CARE WITHOUT WHICH MANY MORE
CALIFORNIANS WOULD SURELY HAVE
DIED. AND WHILE COMMITTEE IS
NOT COVERED NINETEEN
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES ALL WORK
THE SAME AN STD RATES ARE
CURRENTLY SKYROCKETING IN
CALIFORNIA. DO YOU KNOW THAT MY
PATIENTS AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
TODAY HAVE A 40% HIGHER CHANCE
CONTRACT THE SURPLUS AND THEY
DID JUST FIVE YEARS AGO. YOU
ALSO KNOW THAT THESE INJECTIONS
HIT BOTH THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY HARD. OUR CURRENT
MODEL OF NAVIGATING HEALTH
SYSTEMS HAS FAR TOO MANY
BARRIERS THAT CAN ACTUALLY
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM ACCESSING
STD CARE. ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE ACCESSING
CARE INDEPENDENTLY FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME. SB THREE OH SIX
LOWERS THESE CRITICAL BARRIERS
THAT WILL ENSURE STD EITHER
RAPIDLY DETECTED IN TREATED AND
HELP WITH CALIFORNIA BACK IN
CONTROL OF OUR STORY. EXPANDING
AT ACT SB THREE OH SIX INJURIES
YOUNG PEOPLE AREN'T STUCK WITH
THOSE FOR THEIR CARE DENTAL
CARE TO. AND THEY HAVE YOUR
CURRENT PRINTER YOU HAVE- ABOUT
FIFTEEN SECONDS LEFT DERBY
WOULD LIKE TO CONCLUDE YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU BY
EXPANDING INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
LIKE HOME TESTING ENCOUNTER
BASED TESTING CREATES
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVEN THE MOST
DISENFRANCHISED AMONG US TO
KEEP THEMSELVES AND THEIR
PARTNERS SAY. GROUND BEEF SB
THREE OH SIX- PEOPLE OF ALL
AGES RACES GENDERS AND
ORIENTATIONS CAN SAFELY
ENGAGING BACK WITHOUT FEAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I AM TOLD WE HAVE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY WISHING TO
TESTIFY SO WE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY AND SEE IF ANYONE
IS THERE OR WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
THERE SO WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE OH SIX AND WE CAN
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OPERATORS
CAN GO AHEAD GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE WELL FIRST I
START OUT WITH ONE SEVENTY
TODAY THANK YOU PLEASE CONTACT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAN HOARY FROM
WESTERN CENTER ONLINE PROPERTY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WHAT IT
IS THANK YOU THANK YOU A LINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THIRTY SIX. I'M THIRTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR THIRTY
SIX. NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M MOVING ON A LITTLE
NINE ONE THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS COURTNEY MAHER PEARSON
CALLING FOM THE SAN RANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION CO SPONSOR AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I LIVE ONE FORTY
PLEASE CALL AT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRAIG PULLED HER FROM A KILLER
HELP THE PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. TWENTY ONE
FORTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWENTY ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU BY
ONE THIRTY SIX BUT GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALLEN CANNELLA
DOWN WITH WYOMING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY FOR HELP THAT THE
PHARMACIST IS A PART. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WILL BE
HAPPIER WITH A PENCIL ACCESS
HEALTH AND WHERE CROWDS A CROWD
CO SPONSORS. THANK YOU. BY ONE
ELLIS ONE ZERO SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
MICHELLE RETESTED THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ERIN EVAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
NERAL PERPETRATE CALIFORNIA
COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT ON BILL SB THREE ZERO
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
NINETY ONE. HELLO THIS IS MONEY
FOR CORPORATE HEALTH EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT MANAGER WITH FRIENDS
NOBODY IS ENOUGH. AND I AM
CALLING AS THEY ARE BY USING
THIS IS A CO SPONSOR FOR SDGS
SIX AND WE STRONGLY URGE AND
KIND. THANK YOU. IT LOOKS LIKE
ONLINE THIRTY SIX READ YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY SIX.
SORRY ABOUT THAT MAILLET BROKEN
WITH THE INTERNET ABILITY TO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ADAM SURE THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL OF THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS FOR ANY
MACHINE TEST FINE OPPOSITION I
DON'T SEE ANY OPPOSITION
OFFICIALLY. NOTED SO WE WILL GO
TO ANY WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
AND THERE ARE NONE- WE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES THERE WASTING TO
TEST WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- SO MISTER MODERATOR
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THERE. WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. THANKS
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION ON
BILL S. B. REAL SEX AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE AND HAD TO
REFRESH MY SCREEN. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO BILL SB. THREE
ZERO SIX. THE PRESS ONE ZERO
ZERO ONE CUED UP WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT. THIS IS
THE OPERATOR YOUR LINE NUMBER
IS ONE FORTY FIVE ONE FORTY
FIVE OKAY. ONE FORTY FIVE IF
YOU HAVE ANY. FRIENDS YEAH I
THINK IT'S THE WRONG PERSON I
WAS. THE PROTECTED BY. MISTER
MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION.
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SINCE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MORE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MINIMIZER. I AM PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND
I FIRST WANNA. I THANK. THE
CHAIR- FOR- I HAD A SEPARATE
BILL TO AUTHORIZE- HIV
COUNSELLORS TO PROVIDE RAPID
SYPHILIS TESTS IN THE CHAIR
WAS. KIND ENOUGH TO ABSORB THE
BILL INTO THIS. BROADER BILL
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS. A REALLY US A SUPERB
THE BILL NOT TO THE GOOD BILL
BUT A SUPER BILL- WE DO HAVE A
GROWING. PROBLEM WITH
ESCALATION OF. STI'S AND WE
NEED TO MAKE IT. EASY EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO GET TESTED EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO ACCESS. OUR
TREATMENT- AND UNFORTUNATELY IN
CALIFORNIA. EVEN TO GET LIKE AN
HIV TEST IN MOST PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA. IS REALLY HARD. IF
YOU'RE OUTSIDE OF A MERE PARTS
OF SAN FRANCISCO OR WEST
HOLLYWOOD A COUPLE OTHER
PLACES. YOU HAVE TO REALLY
STRUGGLE TO EVEN ACCESS ONE.
AND SO WE NEED TO JUST MAKE IT
EASIER AND EASIER. I'M
PARTICULARLY AUTHORIZING- HIV
COUNSELLORS TO ADMINISTER ANY
RAPID TEST IS REALLY REALLY.
IMPORTANT WE WANT TO GET PEOPLE
TEND TO QUICKLY AND- YOU KNOW I
REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST STARTED
GETTING TESTED FOR HIV AND
STI'S. IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES YOU HAD AGO TESTIMONY
HAD TO COME BACK TWO WEEKS
LATER AND- IT WAS JUST NOT GOOD
IN THE FACT THAT YOU CAN NOW
GET YOUR RESULT AT LEAST THE
PRELIMINARY RESULTS- OFTEN
BEFORE YOU LEAVE. BY THE ALL
THE CLINIC- IS AMAZING BECAUSE
YOU CAN TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION-
THE OTHER PIECE. I JUST WANT TO
REALLY KNOW IS THE PART ABOUT-
IF YOU TEST. IN SOME TO BE A TO
GET- MEDICAID FOR THEIR SEXUAL
PARTNER THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT WITH CHLAMYDIA WORDS
YOU JUST TAKE. CUDDLES AND
EDITORS THAT YOU DON'T TO GET A
SHOT OR ANYTHING ELSE LIKE YOU
DO WITH CONNERY OR- MOORE
SYPHILIS- AND WE CALL THIS- THE
BODY PACK AND IT JUST MAKES ALL
THE SENSE IN THE WORLD YOU
JUST. YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR SEXUAL PARTNER COMMENTING
IT SEPARATELY TESTED EACH OF
THREE. OF THE PERSON GIVEN THE
MEDICATION NO QUESTIONS. ASKED
I THINK THAT THE TERROR
REFERENCES BUT- LET'S FIGURE AS
WE AS A SOCIETY START COMING
OUT OF HER COVER NINETEEN
COCOON AND WE START GETTING
GOING AGAIN- PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO BE ACTIVE AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
SOCIALIZING AND- AND WERE. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO GET OUT
AHEAD OF THIS AND MAKE SURE
THAT AS PEOPLE. BECOME MORE
SOCIAL AND ACTIVE- THAT WE GIVE
THEM ALL THE TOOLS THEY NEED.
TO STAY HEALTHY SO THANK YOU
MISTER. CHAIR FOR THIS BILL AND
I'LL MOVE THE BILL. I THANK YOU
HELLO.LIMóN WELL. YOU HAVE CA.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TO
AS A FORMER HIV PREVENTION
COUNSELOR I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO PROVIDE TESTING BUT
ALSO TO. INSURE AND THAT THERE
IS ACCESS TO TESTING- YOU KNOW
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM. OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES-
AND I AM A FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS US NOT JUST TO THINK
ABOUT WHEN SINGLE ISSUE THE
TRUTH IS THAT WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING WITH. A PATIENT AND
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT RISK
ASSESSMENT. THAT RISK- BLEEDS
INTO OTHER AREAS IT'S NOT JUST
HIV AND SO I A THINK THAT THIS
IS GREAT AND- I APPRECIATE YOU
MOVING IT FORWARD AND WOULD
LOVE TO BE CONSIDERED AS A CO
AUTHOR WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU CENTER LIMON OTHER ANY
OTHER MEMBERS NOBODY BEHIND ME
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
NOW OKAY SENATOR PAYMENTS LIKE
CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SINISTER
SPEAKING OUT AND SUPPORT THE
BILL AND- AND AGAIN DEPRECIATE-
THAT'S THERE TO BE CO AUTHOR
AND A RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON S. B.
YES SIR WIENER DID- CENTER
WIENER. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IN A RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE. ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CONSULTING WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN
BY HAND HI MELINDA'S. EGGMAN
AYE EGGMAN AYE AND SALAS HI AND
SALAS I GROWTH FOR TITLE. LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE LIMóN HI LIMON I
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. HURTADO Y.
NINE. NINE OKAY THAT BILL HAS
NINE VOTES WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR PAN
THE LAST BILL ON THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY IS SB FIVE TEN YOU MAY
PERCEIVE. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR- SOMEPLACE PERCENT SB
FIVE TEN TWO WHICH ADDRESSES-
COST SHARING FOR A COVERED
NINETEEN- TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS I'VE ONE BEGIN BY.
I THINK COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE THE MOCK UP
WHICH WAS SUGGESTED BY THE PART
INSURANCE THOSE AMENDMENTS TO
THE FOLLOWING EXCLUDE
SPECIALIZED HEALTH PLANS
INSURANCE POLICIES INSURANCE
POLICIES COULD BE EXPECTED
BENEFITS SO. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CHOIR DENTAL PLANS VISION PLANS
COVER THIS- CLARIFY- COVERAGE
FOR TESTING AND SERVICES
NECESSARY FOR FURNISHING
IMMUNIZATIONS AND CLARIFY THE
FUTURE FRAMEWORK THAT APPLIES
WHEN THE GOVERNOR DECLARES
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY TO
PREVENT AND MITIGATE DISEASE.
SO SB FIVE TEN REQUIRES HEALTH
PLANS INSURERS COVER COVER
COVER NINETEEN TESTING AND
VACCINATION WITHOUT COST
SHARING A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FROM BOTH IN NETWORKING OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS DURING THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE EXTENDED
TO IN NETWORK PROVIDERS
FOLLOWING THE FEDERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THIS BILL
ALSO PROHIBITS BALANCE BILLING
BY PROVIDERS FOR COVER NINETEEN
TESTING IMMUNIZATIONS EVEN
AFTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. WE CAN ALREADY TAKE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THIS
PANDEMIC AND PUT A FRAMEWORK IN
PLACE TO ALLOW FEDERALLY
APPROVED TESTING ANY MUSICIANS
WITH NO COST SHARING FOR FUTURE
PANDEMIC. FEDERAL STATE
AGENCIES HAVE SENT OUT OF ALL
THE AND SOMETIMES CONFLICTING
GUIDANCE WHICH IS MADE IT
CONFUSING FOR PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS AND KNOW. WHAT WHEN
AND WHAT THEY WILL BE CHARGED.
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR TESTING
SYMPTOMATIC AND ASYMPTOMATIC
AND INDIVIDUALS ALONG WITH
THOSE HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
COVER NINETEEN IS CRUCIAL TO
STOPPING THE SPREAD. THERE'S A
LONG ROAD AHEAD OF US BEFORE
THE MAJORITY POPULATION CAN BE
OURS WILLING TO BE VACCINATED.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WE'VE
CONTINUOUSLY HEARD THAT GETTING
TESTED IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
STOPPING THE SPREAD OF CODE
NINETEEN IN FACT- WE DON'T TEST
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
AROUND US SO WE NEED THAT TO
HAPPEN. WELL THE GENERAL FOCUS
AND PRIORITIES ARE ENSURING
EVERYONE CAN GET A VACCINE WE
CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF ENSURING
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING. AND
VACCINATIONS WITHOUT OUT OF
POCKET COSTS AND THAT'S WHY SB
FIVE TEN IS NEEDED NOW. THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONSISTENT LAWS
REGARDING COVER NINETEEN
TESTING IMMUNIZATIONS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I HAVE BEEN IN
MARTY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND DIANA
DOUGLAS FROM HEALTH ACCESS. TO
TESTIFY HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE- STATED
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND BRANDON MARCHI M. IS
TO MODERATE IF YOU COULD OPEN
HIS LINE PLEASE. THANK YOU SIR
PLEASE I NEED YOUR PHONE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS BRANDON MARCHING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB FIVE TEN WHICH
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO COVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROTECTING
ACTIVATION AND RELATED SERVICES
TO PREVENT OR MITIGATING
PANDEMIC DISEASES SUCH AS COPD
NINETEEN. WITH NO COST SHARING
OR PRIOR AUTHORIZATION DURING A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNMENTS
AND DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN GRAND AND-
MAKE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO HELP BRING THE
STATE FARM HELP BEGIN THE STATE
RESPONSE. TO CORPORATE NINETEEN
IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE TESTING
TREATMENT ACTIVATION FEDERAL
AND STATE POLICIES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED TO MANDATE PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
WITHOUT COST SHARING AND MANY
DIRECTED BERMAN ISSUED THROUGH
EMERGENCYREGULATIONS. AND
DEPARTMENTAL GUIDANCE. ON
OCTOBER SO TWENTY TWENTY.
DEPARTMENT OF IN PUBLISHED IN
OUTLINING I'M SURE REGARD
WAITING HI SHARON ROQUEBRUNE
PRAYER FOR NINETY CAPPING
SCREENING. I DON'T INSURERS ARE
TO COVER TESTING AND TWEAKING
REGARDLESS NETWORK STATUS. OUR
RESPONSE FOR PAYMENT UNDER WAIT
WAIT CROSS DURING AND AFTER
PROVIDERS. I CONTRAST ON JULY
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY. AND
THE MANAGED HEALTHCARE RELEASED
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WHICH
CREATED A SYSTEM BASED ON
WHETHER ONE HAS SYMPTOMS FOR
ONE THING PLAN INSPECTOR.
WHEREBY THERE WERE DIFFERENT
CRITERIA PROTESTING. WHETHER
PATIENT COST SHARING AND
ALLOWED AND WHETHER A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION MAY BE REQUIRED
FOR EACH YEAR. JEFF THE
REGULATIONS ARE SET TO EXPIRE
NEXT MONTH. FEDERAL GUIDANCE
HAS BEEN CLARIFIED THAT
PATIENTS COULD NOT BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR CRUSHING
AMOUNT. THAT WOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO UTILIZATION REVIEW.
AT THE END OF THE DECLARED
EMERGENCY PMAC HAS SENT
FRANKLIN ALL PLAN LETTER TO
REFLECT THE NEW FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOWEVER SB FIVE
TWENTY NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
THE STANDARD OF. CARE
REGULATORS IN CALIFORNIA. YOU
CAN RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED
ANYTIME FASHION WITH NO OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. INTEGRITY FAIR
AND REASONABLE COMPENSATION FOR
THE SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEENTH
AND DENNIS. THE QUESTION
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL WOULD
ALSO PLAY AT ALL COULD BE
NINETY TAX. POSITION PERFORMED.
COVERT TESTING CONTINUES TO BE
NEEDED TO MONITOR AND CONTROL
THAT DESPITE THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE. MISTER RT I HEAR
DIAGNOSED PUBLIC. YET MR CHIEF.
YOU CAN WRAP YOUR COMMENTS
PLEASE THANK YOU. APPLE I THINK
I'M ONE HELL INEQUITY HAVE BEEN
BARE AND HELP DELIVERY. AT THE
FIVE CAN ENSURE ARE ALL ARE
ACCESS TO COVERAGE FOR CLOTHES
NINETEEN NATION INJECTING. THE
IMAGE PROJECTS NOT IMPORT
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR HONOR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THE NEXT WITNESSES
DIANA DOUGLAS WITH HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA MISTER MODERATE IF
YOU COULD OPEN HER LINE PLEASE
AND MISS DOUGLAS. KEEP IN MIND
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
MISTER DOUGLAS PLEASE ADD ME TO
YOUR AND- PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANA DOUGLAS WERE HELD
BACK THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE. SB FIVE HUNDRED ELIMINATE
THE BURDEN OF THE COST SHARING
AND PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR
KOBE IN NINETEEN TESTING AND
IMMUNIZATION FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURANCE- AN EXAMINATION OF
FEDERAL LEVEL GUIDANCE AND
REGULATORY ACTION TEMPLATE
CLASS HEARING BURKE OF THE
NINETEEN CAPPING AN
IMMUNIZATION. PATCHWORK OF
POLICIES IS OFTEN INCONSISTENT
IN ITS ITS RECORD PROVEN VERY
CONFUSING FOR CONSUMERS WITH
COVERAGE OF VARIOUS POINTS-
BEING BEING BASED ON A WHOLE
LOT OF FACTORS INCLUDING
OCCUPATION EXPOSURE AND
SYMPTOMS. NO VACCINE
AVAILABILITY IS INCREASING
SUPPLIES ARE LIMITED AND
INCONSISTENT AMONG VARIOUS
PROVIDERS CLINICS AND HELP
THEM. AND WE PRO STARTING
POINTING BACK THE NFL ABILITY
AND ELIGIBILITY WE JUST CAN'T
AFFORD. TO BE HAMPERED BY
CONFUSION OVER COST SHARING
OBLIGATIONS OR READ THE NEED
FOR PEOPLE TO FIND IN NETWORK
PROVIDERS IS CRITICAL TIME. SB
FIVE HUNDRED HELP CLARIFY
INSURE CALIFORNIANS THAT WHEN
THEY NEED SOMETHING
INTIMIDATION IT WILL BE COVERED
NO MATTER WHAT THE WILLALSO
HELP THE FELLOWSHIP REMARKS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A REPLAY OF
THE PAST YEARS CONFUSION AND
THE ADVENT OF THE FUTURE
PANDEMICS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES RELATED TO DISEASE
THAT. FOR THE RIGHT REASONS WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
TEN AND RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST
YOUR AYE BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER DOUGLAS- AND IF. THE
JOB AND HEALTH- CAN DOES NOT
WORK I BELIEVE YOU HAVE IF IN.
BECAUSE YOU WERE WAY AND TWO
YEAR TIME LIMIT- WE WILL MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLEY WISHING
TO SIGN SUPPORT NO ONE. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NO ONE IS THERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SO MOVED TO
THE PHONE LINES NOW MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD. PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING- AND REMIND
THEM THAT THEY ARE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
PLEASE. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE TEN AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE TEN. AND
OUR FIRST PERSON IS ONLINE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT I'M SURE SIR BRAMBELL
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NOW TWO LINES SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY SEVENTY
NINE IS YOUR PHONE AND- EVERY
GIRL THANK YOU SURE. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
ALEX CON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE. ONE FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE THIS IS RIGHT OKAY
LIKE THE REST OF ALLIANCE
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR MODERATOR- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION AND
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS.
OPPOSITION THAT IS LISTED AS
JED HAMPTON WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS AND
STEPHANIE WATKINS THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
MISTER MODERATOR HE WOULD OPEN
THEIR LINES AND TELL MISTER
HAMPTON HE'S FREE TO PROCEED.
WITH TWO MINUTES. MISTER
HAMPTON YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH PLANS AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE OPPORTUNITY BACK FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. WE DO
WANT TO SAY THAT OUR MEMBER
OUTLANDER STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS ONE OF
MY. BEING OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. THE DAILY NEWS
PUBLIC EMERGENCIES. I REMEMBER
HOW TO TAKE INCREASE SEVEN TO
THE BACK. TO HELP CURB SPREAD
OF COLOR NINETEEN- HOUSE WE ARE
CONCERNED- THE AT BY PIN. WE
ALL MET LANGUAGE. THAT HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS ARE REQUIRED
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING PER CODE NINETEEN WHEN
THE LIGHTS ARE OFF RIGHT
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER AND
MINISTER TO RECRUITMENT ROWLEY
PROTEST. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ABSENCE OF THE CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO CREATE
INCONSISTENCIES WITH THE
RECENTLY RELEASED FEDERAL DIED
IN THE CURRENT STATE
REGULATIONS. A SPECIFICALLY THE
UPDATED FEDERAL GUIDANCE WHICH
WAS RELEASED ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
SIXTH OF THIS YEAR WE AFFIRM
PREVIOUS FEDERAL GUIDANCE. THAT
THAT THAT STATE THAT HEALTH
PLANS INSURERS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO PAY FOR TESTING BUT NOT USED
FOR DIAGNOSTIC PURPOSES. I
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE CRITICAL
TESTING PER VERY FOR THOSE THAT
ARE NOT PRIMARILY INTENDED FOR
INDIVIDUALIZED DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING OR TREATMENT FOR COLD
AT NINETEEN. WE BELIEVE THAT
OMITTING THE IMPORTANT THINGS
IN THE BILL COULD CAUSE
CONFUSION AND FRUSTRATION AMONG
PATIENTS SEEKING ATTACK. A WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE BILL
BE AMENDED TO BETTER ALIGN THE
CURRENT FEDERAL BY. STATE
REGULATION BY CLARIFYING THAT
PLANTS RSPONSIBILITIES FOR
COVERAGE OF DIAGNOSTIC TESTING.
AMONG OTHER THINGS WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT THE FIGHT. TO
RETROACTIVELY OBLIGATE HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS TO REIMBURSE
PROVIDERS ON THE POTENTIALLY
LACASSE HERE FROM THE START OF
THE FEDERALLY. DECLARED PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. IN THIS
EMERGENCY HAS CREATED BY TOWN
PERCENT PROVIDER. WHICH IS WHY
HEALTH PLAN SET UP TO MEET THEM
BY PROVIDING. FIND THANK YOU
FOR. WHERE HE BOUGHT A PROBE.
HOWEVER ARE UNCLEAR THAT THE
PERSON HOW DESPERATE PROJECTS
PREVENT IF YOU. I WOULD ALL
COME WORKING CONFINES OF
EXISTING LAW. FOR THESE REASONS
WE WERE OPPOSE SB AND UNLESS
THERE'S A MAN. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK THE
AUTHOR THE MEASURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER HAD TO MISS
MURDER IF YOU WOULD- OPENS
OPENS. ONE LAW PLEASE. SPIKE IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
WASHINGTON FROM BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
REGRETTABLY WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON SB
FIVE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF OUR THOUGHTS AND
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO THIS
MEASURE. ALSO LIKE I CAN MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS AND
ALSO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU SOME
ADDITIONAL ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE VILLAGE DRAFTED. AT
THE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED OUR
MEMBERS STEPPED UP EARLY TO
WORK WITH BOTH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS TO TRACK ANY
POTENTIAL BARRIERS THERE WERE
TWO PEOPLE SPEAKING COVERED
RELATED TESTING AND OR
SERVICES. THIS IS CRITICAL OF
THE. UNDERSTOOD AND
ACKNOWLEDGED. AGING P. HAVE
BEEN AND TREATED SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE CURB CREDIT FOR THE NIGHT.
I THINK THAT THE PEOPLE OF THE-
ISSUE THE RIGHT THE RESPECT OUT
OF NETWORK COVERAGE AND
GOVERNMENT CHARGES WERE NOTABLY
OUT OF LINE WITH THE NORM. ON
THE VARIANCE WE ARE CONCERNED I
THINK BY TEN DOES NOT ESTABLISH
A CLEAR METHODOLOGY OF
REVERSING OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDERS. CURRENTLY THE BILL
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO REIMBURSE OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS FOR ALL
PASSING ITEMS OR SERICES AT A
REASONABLE RATE. UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE'S OFTEN MUCH
DISAGREEMENT WITH RESPECT TO
WHAT CONSTITUTES A REASONABLE
RATE. WE WOULD RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING THE MEDICARE RATE.
AS AN APPROPRIATE ALTERNATIVE.
WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT A
REASONABLE MARKET BASED PRICING
BENCHMARK OF THE TABLET.
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE IRS HHS AND
FEEL I'LL HAVE DONE REGARDING
VACCINES WHILE ALSO ENSURING.
AGAINST PRICE GOUGING WHICH AS
I MENTIONED SADLY IT'S NOT BEEN
AN UNCOMMON OCCURRENCE SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. LASTLY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PROVISIONS
ADDRESSING FUTURE PANDEMIC
CONTAINED IN THE BILL ARE
PREMATURE. DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE
NEXT GLOBAL PANDEMIC BOOKER AND
BACHELOR THE DEFINING
PARAMETERS FOR FUTURE PANDEMIC
WITHOUT ANY KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT
HAPPENED PRACTICES TREATMENT
OPTIONS THEIR VACCINES.
AVAILABILITY WILL EXIT
CONCERNING. FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE. OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORED MONSTER TO
DRESS ARE CONCERNED. THAT THE
BILL FOR IT TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESS WHICH TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE- AND
THERE ISN'T ONE WE WILL. TO
ROOM FOUR. THERE IS NO ONE
THERE WISHING TO TEST. SO WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES AND
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
OPEN UP PHONE LINES AND LET
PEOPLE KNOW THEY CAN. TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION NOW WITH NAME
TITLE AND POSITION ONLY PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO VOICE YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND OUR FIRST IS ONE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BENNINGER MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS WITH. ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CAP AN
APPLICANT REMAIN OPPOSED MOMENT.
THANK YOU. AND NOW TO LINE ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU I'M ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT HIM STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
NOW TO LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS NICHOLA
CONCERNS SENATE AND I. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATE
IF YOU COULD JUST REMIND THE
COLORS THIS IS- FOR OPPOSITION
RIGHT NOW. OKAY AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
OPPOSITION. ONE NINE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. OKAY
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR GREAT
JOB AND WE HAVE NO MRE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR ANY DISCUSSION IS
ANYONE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. NO. OKAY THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
LEYVA- SENATOR PAN I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
RESPONDING TO THE- COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU- CENTER
MELINDA'S- CERTAINLY WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON ON THIS BILL- I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT FIRST OF
ALL- YOU ACCESS TO TESTING
VACCINATIONS ARE BOTH ESSENTIAL
TO BEING ABLE TO HOLD NOT ONLY
THIS PANDEMIC BRING PETER
PANDEMIC AS WELL IN FACT- WHEN
THINGS ARE PROBABLY LED TO THIS
PANDEMIC TAKING OFF IN THE
UNITED STATES WAS ACTUALLY LACK
OF ACCESS TO TESTING WHERE
THEREFORE WE SAW A TREMENDOUS
YEAH WE SAW SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE BUT WE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF TESTING AND OF COURSE-
VACCINATION ACCESS TO
VACCINATIONS. IS GOING TO BE
WHAT'S GONNA HELP US STOP THIS
PANDEMIC I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
TO IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE- JUST TO CLARIFY- IN
THE FAQ THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PUT OUT- THE
MAINTAIN DEPARTMENT CLARIFIED
THAT COVERAGE FOR CERTAIN ITEMS
SERVICES MUST BE PROVIDED
CONSISTENT REQUIREMENTS OF
SECTION SIX OF THE ONE OF THE
FSC ARE A GOOD SAYS WHEN
MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THE TERM BY THE
INDIVIDUALS ATTENDING
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER SO
ESSENTIALLY THE GUIDANCE IS
THAT IS ALIGNED WITH WHAT THIS
BILL SAYS THAT IF THE PHYSICIAN
ORDERS TO TEST IT NEEDS TO BE
COVERED- AND- SO CERTAINLY WE
CAN- YOU KNOW WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON AND THE
INTERPRETATION SO I THINK THEY
HAVE ONE INTERPRETATION BUT-
YOU LOOK AT THE FAQS- FROM THE-
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IT'S ACTUALLY MORE CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IN
THIS BILL. BUT AGAIN I
CERTAINLY WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TO BE SURE THAT PEOPLE DO
HAVE ACCESS TO TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS WHICH ARE BOTH
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO STOP
NOT ONLY THIS PANDEMIC BUT ALSO
FUTURE PANDEMICS AS WELL AND-
SO WITH THAT- I THINK. YOUR
QUESTION. OKAY SO- YES SECURING.
AND TO WORK WITH THE OP. TO
CLARIFY OF THE DEFINITIONS
WITHIN THE BILL AND MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING'S IN CONFORMITY YES
OF COURSE YES OKAY. SO I DON'T
THINK. WATER BILL- RIGHT YES I
HAD TOO AND WE SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THEY'RE NOT OKAY SO- WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB FIVE TEN FROM
SENATOR A LEYVA ALTHOUGH I
THINK SENATOR WIENER MIGHT BE
HER I DON'T KNOW- THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR PAN. DID
YOU WANT. TO FURTHER CLOSE ON
THIS BILL OR- RESPECT YES WHEN
I LOOK AT YOU OKAY. GREAT THEN-
MADAM CONSULTANT YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH
FOR TADO FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA
LEYVA AYE LIMON. HI LIMON I
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER BY WIENER BY. THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU THAT BILL HAS
NINE VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND I DO
KNOW WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
MEMBER IN SENATE RULES WHOSE
ASSET THE ROLE BE HELD OPEN
CENTER PAN BUT BACK TO YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS
ACTOR CONSENT CALENDAR- AND
IT'S MAKE NO WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THOSE
ARE. AGAIN ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY HER TADO
WHICH THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASS AS AMENDED REFER TO.
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER SIX
FOUR FOUR SB FOUR FOUR ONE BY
CENTER TADO MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASS REFER TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M NUMBER
SEVEN SB FIVE SIXTY FIVE I
CENTER JONES THE MOTION WOULD
BE DO PASS REFER TO COMMUNITY
DID CHERRY. AND THEN ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. ON THE TICKETS.
WHICH IS SB SIX EIGHTY TWO BUT
CENTER RUBIO AND THE WOULD BE
THE MOST WOULD BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS AS EMOTIONALLY
SENT CALENDAR. SEATS MOTION BY
CENTER LEYVA- CONSULT PLEASE
THE ROLL NEXT ENCOUNTER. PAN HI
CAN MULLIN THIS AYE LINDA'S AYE
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN YE AND
SALAS. AND SALAS I GROWTH FOR
TADO. FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA
AYE LEóN HI LIMON AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER I. CONSENT
CALIFORNIA'S TEN VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS LET'S GO FIRST OF ALL
SERGEANTS HE PLEASE JUST
NOTIFYING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE RE OPENING
THE ROLES I KNOW THERE'S SOME
PEOPLE RUNNING OFF SOME MAY
HAVE CONFLICTS LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH THE AGENDA AND- OPEN
RULES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- SO
STARTING WITH- FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB FIVE TWENTY ONE- THAT I
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HELLO HER TADA I'M
RETARDED BY. LEON HI LIMON AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. OKAY SO THAT
THOSE CURRENTLY TEN ZERO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NEXT ITEMS I'M NUMBER
TWO S. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD I CANCELED PLEASE
ROLL OPEN THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS GROW LIMON HI. LIMóN I.
OKAY THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS-
TEN VOTES AT TEN ZERO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS-
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB 2405% GONZALEZ GROW.
LIMON HI LIMóN I RUBIO. RUBIO
I. ASIDE. EIGHT TO. BUT NOT
THAT IT'S ALWAYS. THAT I. NOW
THAT I HAVE. THE BILL.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH. OKAY FELL- AGAIN
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO FORTY FIVE A SERRA GONZALEZ
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HER TARA. OKAY.
AND THE POLITICAL REALM
PROVIDED ON THIS ONE RIGHT. THE
VOTE ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE IS
EIGHT TO- THAT BILL AS IT
PASSES. OKAY NEXT ITEM IS. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AS BEFORE- TO
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS GROW LIMON.
LIMON I RUBIO HI RUBIO I. TEN
TEN OKAY THAT BILLS CURRENTLY
TEN ZERO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX FOUR
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA A CONSOLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROSS THE MOON. THE
MOON I THAT. OKAY ACTUALLY
WE'RE ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
SIX FOUR FOUR BY CENTER LEYVA.
GROVE I IRVINE. OKAY STEP BILLS
OUT ELEVEN ZERO- NEXT BILL IS-
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB THREE OH SIX
BY CENTER PAN- CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ GROW NO GROWTH NO.
IT'S. NINE ONE. RIGHT OKAY BUT
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ONE FIVE
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SB FIVE TEN BY CENTER PAN US
THEY CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELENDEZ GROWTH NO GROWTH NO.
YEAH YEAH APTOS OUT NINE ONE
ALL RIGHT AND- LET'S GO BACK-
AND THEN WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- SO- CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GROSS HI GROVE HI.
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT ELEVEN
ZERO NOW WE'RE GING TO GO BACK
TO THE TOP OF THE ROLE- SO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE BY CENTER BRADFORD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROW I GROW BY. ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT ELEVEN ZERO NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
BY SENATOR DODD CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
GROW HI I. ELEVEN ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. ELEVEN ZERO. AND I
THINK THE STACK IT- HOLD ON-
ITEM NUMBER FIVE- SP FOUR OH
TWO BY SENATOR TADO. ITS OWN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS GROW HIGH GROWTH I.
THAT BILLS OUT ELEVEN ZERO. AND
I BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA EVERYTHING. EVERYONE
WELL GOOD SEARCH HERE I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH ME WITH MY DOUBLE
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENT THANK YOU
OF COURSE YES OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO GET OKAY. ALL RIGHT
OKAY SO THIS CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA OF THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I
WANT TO AGAIN THANK OUR
WONDERFUL STAFF AND OUR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT PEOPLE YOU
MAKE IT ALL SOUND SO EASY BUT
WE KNOW IT'S NOT AND ALSO I
THINK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE. HEALTH
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR TO SUGGEST ARE IMPORTANT
TO US WE WERE INCLUDE TESTIMONY
IN THE FIFTH HEARING. THANK YOU
FOR THE- WITH THAT COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH IS A THANK YOU.